programming throwdown episode 171 compilers and interpreters take Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. This is super exciting. We got this request from a listener. Maybe later on the show, I'll find out, remind myself who it was. But they said, how about you folks do compilers, interpreters? I can't believe we haven't done this episode. It seems so pivotal to everything we do in software engineering. But yeah, here we are to lead the way.
Programming Throwdown 第 171 期：编译器与解释器。开始吧，Jason。嘿，大家好。这太令人兴奋了。我们收到了听众的这个请求。也许节目稍后我会查一下，提醒自己是谁提的。但他们说，你们为什么不讲讲编译器和解释器呢？真不敢相信我们还没做过这一期。这似乎是我们软件工程中所做一切的核心。但没错，我们现在就来带大家了解一下。
I have to confess, I don't know as much about Compiler's Interpreter as Patrick. So Patrick's really going to carry the water here. But I will add color commentary as appropriate um and before we get into that I wanted to talk about monitor setups for a little bit so I I was working next to somebody who had three monitors like side by side by side and they had three different things going on you know like they had one was for coding the other one was for email and i thought this was really compelling i thought oh this is a great idea and uh i just can't get myself to do it basically i just have to have just one thing
我必须承认，我对编译器和解释器的了解不如 Patrick。所以 Patrick 真的要挑大梁了。但我会适时地补充一些花絮。嗯，在进入正题之前，我想先聊聊显示器设置。我之前和一个有三台显示器并排摆放的人一起工作，他们同时在做三件不同的事，比如一台用来写代码，另一台用来收发邮件。我觉得这真的很吸引人，心想这真是个好主意。但我自己却做不到，基本上我必须只专注于一件事，
in front of me and uh and and just uh keep alt tabbing to go to different things. I haven't figured out how to drag from one desk screen to the other and do all of that. What is your setup? Do you have an array of monitors, or what do you do? Yeah, eight? Seriously? I do all my programming in VR, so I just have as many as i actually do look for it i think that'll be cool one day one day um that day is not today um i just have one big one uh but i
在我面前，然后不停地用 Alt+Tab 切换到不同的窗口。我还没弄明白怎么把窗口从一个屏幕拖到另一个屏幕，以及所有那些操作。你的设置是什么样的？你有一排显示器吗，还是怎么弄的？什么，八台？认真的吗？我所有的编程工作都在 VR 里完成，所以我实际上想用多少就有多少。我觉得有一天这会很酷，嗯，那一天不是今天。我只有一个大显示器，但我
also have a ipad off to the side that i use for for my conferencing uh for video conferencing um that works well for me so i guess it's two, but one big one for sort of similar reasons to what you're saying, like that. Normally, if you have two monitors, you just get them extra wide or on top of each other, which is too much versus one big monitor, I feel you don't end up with that awkward split in the middle or have to shift one far to the side. Right? I will say for people who do like simulation race games or flight games, having three for a gaming setup would be really cool because you're one thing over three and the people who do of course the you know stock trading where they're actually just it's mostly focused on one task right like they're all of it is related there's just lots of you know dials and metrics it's akin to i think like a cockpit in an airplane
旁边还有一个 iPad，我用它来开视频会议。这对我来说很管用，所以我想算是两台吧。但我用一个大显示器的原因和你说的差不多。通常如果你有两台显示器，要么把它们放得特别宽，要么上下堆叠，这都太过了。相比之下，一个大显示器不会在中间出现尴尬的缝隙，也不用把头扭到一边去，对吧？我会说，对于那些玩模拟赛车或飞行游戏的人来说，三台显示器的游戏设置会非常酷，因为你的视野跨越了三个屏幕。当然，那些做股票交易的人，他们主要专注于一项任务，对吧？所有内容都是相关的，只是有很多仪表和指标，我觉得这就像飞机的驾驶舱一样，
where there's many many indicators some are lower priority but they're kind of very related to a singular task to me it seems a little bit different like when you're doing your programming email is maybe that's not fair I don't know then I've never been those other things but it feels like a different task slack or email they feel different to the task of coding and so yeah I'm with you like i don't feel compelled to have them up on the side yeah you know i used to do um i used to have a my laptop so like my laptop right now is just mirroring the screen of of the main main display i used to have it kind of like what you're saying or sort of secondary screen but um i found myself not
有很多指示器，有些优先级较低，但它们与单一任务非常相关。对我来说，这似乎有点不同。当你编程时，邮件可能——也许这样说不公平，我不知道，因为我从来没做过那些工作——但我觉得这和编程是不同的任务。Slack 或邮件，它们给人的感觉与编程任务不同。所以，是的，我和你一样，我并不觉得有必要把它们放在旁边。是的，你知道，我以前用我的笔记本电脑，所以就像我现在的笔记本电脑只是镜像了主显示器的画面。我以前把它当作副屏幕，但我发现自己
paying attention in meetings even when i should be and uh um and i just i kind of couldn't do that i guess well i mean isn't this like a trope that people can't actually multitask we just sequentially singular task yeah yeah i mean i i just uh um but yeah i mean i do envy the people who can have like three different screens on and not be distracted i will say i i do find i it's not all bad i think if you occasionally need like a paper or document or you're implementing an algorithm and you want to consult something or the few times i've had the kind of i'm generating some kind of output or whatever that's visual um it's very cool to have a extra real estate where when i update something and click you know test i can sort of
在开会时即使应该专心，也无法集中注意力。我大概做不到那样。嗯，这难道不是人们其实无法多任务处理，只能顺序处理单一任务的陈词滥调吗？是的，是的，我是说，但我确实羡慕那些能同时开三个屏幕而不分心的人。不过我得说，我发现这也不全是坏事。如果你偶尔需要参考论文或文档，或者你在实现一个算法，想查阅某些资料，或者在我生成某种输出或视觉效果的几次经历中，拥有额外的屏幕空间是非常酷的。当我更新代码并点击测试时，我可以
still see the code but see the results and you know up inside you know screen real estate can be very very useful so i'll never sort of say something bad against someone who who wants to have more screens but the variety is yeah it's it is very interesting yeah i wonder um you know now that i'm working from home it's less of an issue but when i was going into the office i was running into problems where you know my home monitor and my office monitor aren't the same and so you know it wouldn't quite extend the desktop the right way and things would get all messed up that's the thing i've been picky about is i have my monitor pretty high i'm i'm fairly tall so um i want you know my monitor nice and high so i either put little plastic risers or put it on a monitor arm and lift it up so i have it higher than i think what i see a lot of other people do just because
仍然看到代码，同时看到结果。你知道，屏幕空间确实非常非常有用。所以我永远不会说那些想要更多屏幕的人的坏话，但这种多样性确实非常有趣。是的，我想知道，嗯，现在我在家工作，这已经不是什么大问题了，但当我还在办公室时，我经常遇到问题，比如我的家用显示器和办公室显示器不一样，所以它无法正确扩展桌面，一切都会变得一团糟。我比较挑剔的一点是，我把显示器放得很高，我个子比较高，所以我想让显示器保持在很高的高度。所以我要么放一些塑料垫高架，要么用显示器支架把它抬起来，所以我把它放得比我看到的其他人都要高，只是因为
it feels unnatural to me all right we have to have a we have to have a bake off here my monitor is on a i'm trying to eyeball it maybe like an eight inch riser what about you oh i'm trying from the bottom of my screen i'm like at a like a foot like oh wow okay that's even bigger i might be yeah a little bit more than eight inches but yeah that is pretty tall so like the when you look at your monitor at eye level are you looking at the center of it i wish it's not quite that high the monitor i'm going to go quite the high so it's uh yeah i'm looking at like just above something like 60 up from the bottom yeah okay it makes sense yeah i'm about maybe like 75 or so up from the bottom but yeah if i didn't have any riser the monitor like my eye level would be
那样对我来说感觉更自然。好吧，我们得来比一比。我的显示器放在一个——我试着目测一下——大概 8 英寸高的垫高架上。你呢？哦，我试着从屏幕底部算起，大概有一英尺高。哦，哇，好吧，那确实更高。我可能，是的，比 8 英寸多一点，但那确实相当高。那么，当你平视显示器时，你是看着它的中心吗？我希望是这样，但没那么高。我用的显示器没那么高，所以，是的，我大概看着离底部 60% 的位置。好吧，有道理。我大概在离底部 75% 左右的位置。但如果我不垫高，显示器的高度，我的视线会
above the top of the monitor it's just but i see people do that all the time i don't i i can't yeah it's like um i think your neck would get hurt i think if you do if you keep it like that what i want to try is one of the very wide curved monitors i think that would be really cool yeah you know i've i've tried it i i have one um um at work and it's it's pretty good it's pretty good i will will say that the one I have, the refresh rate isn't as good. It's not, it's not like,
在显示器顶部上方。这太……但我看到人们总是那样做。我不行，我觉得你的脖子会受伤。如果你一直那样保持的话。我想尝试的是那种非常宽的曲面显示器，我觉得那会很酷。是的，你知道，我试过，我在公司有一台，它相当不错，相当不错。但我得说，我那台的刷新率没那么好。它不是，它不是那种，
you know, a deal breaker or anything, but you do like, if you have one monitor, it has twice the refresh rate of the other. It can kind of like, it's like when you're at the store and all the differences between the TVs are so noticeable
你知道，决定性的因素什么的，但你确实会觉得，如果你有一台显示器，它的刷新率是另一台的两倍。这有点像你在商店里，电视之间的所有差异都非常明显，
but you take it home you totally lose your frame of reference right so if you have like a four to three aspect ratio or whatever like not a 1080p widescreen 16 to 9 but like if it's curved left and right does it also curve up and down if you get a nice tall one like or i don't is like on a sphere i've never looked it up i guess i should the one i have i'm looking at it right now um it's it's curved but just you know it's just curved like like a cylinder like a cylinder okay yeah and but it's very wide and not very tall so the aspect ratio is not it's not hd aspect ratio it's much wider oh okay i think i would want one that yeah i think i just want like a very large like probably 8k but like you know big but then i wouldn't actually run it you know i would everything would be scaled up just so it's a comfortable eyesight thing i think 8k would be
但当你把它带回家，你就完全失去了参照系，对吧？所以如果你有一个 4:3 的纵横比，或者其他什么，而不是 1080p 的 16:9 宽屏，但如果它是左右弯曲的，它会上下也弯曲吗？如果你买一个很高的那种，或者我不知道，它是在一个球面上吗？我从来没查过，我想我应该查一下。我用的那台，我现在正看着它，它是弯曲的，但只是，你知道，它就像一个圆柱体，像一个圆柱体。好吧，是的，而且它非常宽，高度不高，所以纵横比不是高清纵横比，它要宽得多。哦，好吧。我想我会想要一个，是的，我想我只想要一个非常大的，可能是 8K 的，但你知道，很大。但我实际上不会以那个分辨率运行它，我会把一切都放大，只是为了让视力更舒适。我觉得 8K 会
too small at like minimum resolution or whatever yeah right um but yeah folks out there let us know your monitor setup i'm curious i do feel like i could do better um and uh yeah curious to know what what people's setups are out there just chat us email us post in discord um discord is is getting more popular so people posting some funny jokes there was this video of this professor pranking his class which i thought was hilarious so thanks wait wait what a professor ranking to their class okay i had to go on discord but pranking their class oh pranking i just said ranking i was like yes i was like oh yes we all know that they do that but they're not supposed to actually do it
在最小分辨率下太小了，或者其他什么。是的，没错。嗯，但听众朋友们，让我们知道你们的显示器设置，我很好奇。我觉得我还可以做得更好。嗯，是的，很好奇大家现在的设置是什么样的。在 Discord 上和我们聊天、发邮件或发帖。Discord 越来越受欢迎了，所以人们在那里发了一些有趣的笑话。有一个教授恶作剧他的班级的视频，我觉得太搞笑了。等等，等等，什么？一个教授恶作剧他的班级？好吧，我得去 Discord 上看看。恶作剧他们的班级？哦，恶作剧。我刚才说成了排名（ranking）。我当时想，是的，我们都知道他们会那样做，但他们其实不应该真的那样做。
rate my students.com new website all right well we'll jump over to the news of the show starting off since last time uh i mentioned this and then jason was excited about it as well so so i feel we'll talk about it here uh i the headlines everyone's probably seen them but but i feel like it's pretty cool for for something that is a memorable part of my childhood which is being absolutely crushed and being terrible at the game of tetris um but but now uh there has been someone who has beaten tetris actually as of recording this show i think two people have done it uh so the world record didn't last very long after lasting for years and years um but blue scutie i think the first name is is willis uh beat tetris first not at the earliest possible time which was accomplished now but uh did tetris first not at the earliest possible time
给我的学生打分（Rate My Students.com），新网站。好吧，我们跳到节目新闻。从上次开始，我提到了这个，Jason 也对此很兴奋，所以我觉得我们在这里聊聊。标题大家可能都看过了，但我感觉对于我童年记忆中不可或缺的一部分来说，这真的很酷，那就是在《俄罗斯方块》游戏中被彻底碾压，玩得一塌糊涂。但现在，有人已经通关了《俄罗斯方块》。实际上，在录制这期节目时，我想已经有两个人做到了。所以世界纪录在保持了多年之后，并没有持续太久。但 Blue Scutie，我想名字是 Willis，第一个通关了《俄罗斯方块》，不是在最早可能的时间，那是现在才完成的，但他确实先通关了，不是在最早可能的时间，
which was accomplished now but i did beat it and here actually the the reason why i think it it's worth mentioning on the show aside from just being a cool cool thing and i linked the the video there that is the first place i saw it um but it's interesting how they define beat here so when you know tetris was originally built they didn't actually have an end game in mind, which is kind of unusual. It would just play faster and faster. And I guess the assumption was just, it was so fast, you couldn't possibly keep going.
那是现在才完成的，但我确实通关了。这里实际上是我认为值得在节目中提及的原因，除了它是一件很酷的事情之外，我还在那里链接了视频，那是我第一次看到它的地方。但有趣的是他们在这里如何定义“通关”。当《俄罗斯方块》最初被开发时，他们并没有考虑到结局，这有点不寻常。它只会玩得越来越快。我想当时的假设是，它太快了，你不可能一直玩下去。
And so you eventually would die. A lot of games actually of that era are like that. Like Donkey Kong, actually, in Donkey Kong, the amount of time you have to finish the level goes down every time you have completed a full revolution of all the levels. And basically you get to a point where there just literally isn't enough time to finish the first level, even if you're frame perfect. And that's just how it ends. So Tetris, I guess, gets faster and faster. And then at some point it basically kind of caps out like it it just doesn't go any faster um and for a long time uh people would get to that area
所以你最终会死掉。那个时代很多游戏其实都是这样的。比如《大金刚》，实际上在《大金刚》中，你完成关卡的时间会随着你完成所有关卡的完整循环而减少。基本上你会达到一个点，即使你的操作是完美帧（frame perfect），也根本没有足够的时间来完成第一关。这就是它的结局。所以《俄罗斯方块》，我想，变得越来越快。然后在某个点，它基本上就封顶了，它不会再变快了。嗯，很长一段时间，人们会到达那个区域，
that that speed and then just sort of you know die pretty quickly if their their row count was low they would be able to you know you know manage to maybe get a few more lines cleared and then die. But then recently, people discovered a new way of pounding, tapping the, you know, controller faster and faster with this crazy two handed technique. And they've been able to go faster and faster and began to discover, which I guess people had figured out via, you know, tool assisted speed running. So they had kind of known this would happen. But humans began to be able to get there, which is levels where, you know, incrementing the color palette left the predefined color palette and would start using actually machine instructions as the color selection, which would result in just really ill formed colors that made it even more difficult. But then eventually, a portion of memory would be accessed that would just cause basically uh you know a
那个速度，然后如果他们的行数很低，他们就会很快死掉。他们也许能设法再消除几行，然后就死掉。但最近，人们发现了一种新的敲击方式，用这种疯狂的双手技术越来越快地敲击控制器。他们已经能够越来越快，并开始发现——我想人们已经通过工具辅助速通（TAS）弄清楚了这一点，所以他们已经知道会发生这种情况——但人类开始能够达到那个水平，也就是增加调色板会超出预定义的调色板，并开始使用机器指令作为颜色选择，这会导致非常畸形的颜色，使游戏变得更加困难。但最终，内存的一部分会被访问，这基本上会导致
corruption of of the data and so when that happens the game the game just crashes and stops and just hangs um and so this is what uh blue scooty managed to do was to to basically cause the game to try to execute code that wasn't code uh and then hung the game and so first person to do that it's just it's crazy it's very fascinating it's also and it's the same you know as jason was mentioning sort of frame perfect analysis for uh super mario brothers is some any sort of speed running game that is from around that era the amount of analysis and reverse engineering that goes into it and there are even patched versions of the game so that like it doesn't get weird and you can keep playing or you know just other things where people really really understand the mechanisms that uh you know
数据损坏。所以当这种情况发生时，游戏就会崩溃、停止并挂起。这就是 Blue Scutie 设法做到的，基本上导致游戏尝试执行不是代码的代码，然后挂起了游戏。所以他是第一个做到这一点的人，这太疯狂了，非常迷人。而且，正如 Jason 提到的，这和《超级马里奥兄弟》的完美帧分析是一样的，任何那个时代左右的速通游戏，投入其中的分析和逆向工程量都非常大。甚至还有游戏的补丁版本，这样它就不会变得奇怪，你可以继续玩，或者其他人们真正理解在结局时发生的机制的事情。
take place at this end game and the amount of analysis i'm sure the programmers at the time had no idea that you know for 30 years 40 years people would be uh sort of thinking about uh what that code that they wrote in the back of a cubicle you know somewhere and and turned out yeah it's totally wild right i think uh yeah yeah the uh yeah that that whole thing where they they do this crazy i mean you really have to see it almost in slow motion this way with two hands so the idea is every frame you know in tetris there's no inertia or momentum or anything like that with the with the pieces so you know every frame if you could get like a press left and a stop pressing left in those two frames then you could move it over um one whole column and uh and so yeah they do this weird thing where i guess they they hit hit the joystick from the bottom. Um, so in other words, like if you were imagine like just pressing with your thumb on a button, like you had another thumb kind of on the bottom of the
我敢肯定，当时的程序员根本不知道，30 年、40 年后，人们会思考他们在某个隔间后面写的那些代码。结果证明，这太疯狂了，对吧？我想，是的，是的，他们做这种疯狂操作的整个过程，你几乎必须以慢动作观看，用两只手。所以这个想法是，每一帧，你知道在《俄罗斯方块》中，方块没有任何惯性或动量之类的东西。所以，你知道，每一帧，如果你能在两帧内完成“按左”和“停止按左”，那么你就可以把它移动一整列。所以，是的，他们做了这种奇怪的事情，我想他们从底部敲击操纵杆。换句话说，如果你想象一下，就像用拇指按一个按钮，就像你的另一个拇指在控制器底部一样？
controller? And so one thumb is pressing and releasing, but then the other thumb is pressing the bottom into the first thumb. And like, I guess by doing that, you can get more presses than you could with just one, one thumb. It's, it's totally crazy. You have to see it i mean i guess tetris uh lends itself to that because you i i don't know i we we'd have to learn more but i guess you only have to move either left or right as long as you don't overshoot and you only have to rotate the piece three times in a in a direction and then you would you know just be back so you can only rotate at 90 degrees so there's like a finite number of presses if you knew exactly what you were doing your path planning uh you could be very minimal inputs
所以一个拇指在按压和释放，但另一个拇指在把底部推向第一个拇指。我想通过这样做，你可以比只用一个拇指获得更多的按压次数。这太疯狂了。你必须亲眼看看。我的意思是，我想《俄罗斯方块》本身就适合这样做，因为你——我不知道，我们得深入了解一下——但我想你只需要向左或向右移动，只要你不按过头，并且你只需要将方块旋转三次，然后你就会回到原位。所以你只能旋转 90 度，所以按键次数是有限的。如果你确切地知道自己在做什么，你的路径规划，你可以用最少的输入。
yep yep totally um all right on to pal world accused of being an ai product um so yeah so pal world is wild patrick and i were talking about it before the show. It really like is a great area, a great, you know, theme for a game. Basically it's adult theme, well, not adult theme, that means something totally different. Pokemon with guns. It's Pokemon with guns.
是的，是的，完全正确。好吧，转到《幻兽帕鲁》（Palworld），被指控为 AI 产品。所以，是的，《幻兽帕鲁》太疯狂了。Patrick 和我在节目开始前聊过它。它确实是一个灰色地带，一个很棒的、你知道，游戏主题。基本上它是成人主题——嗯，不是成人主题，那意味着完全不同的东西。带枪的宝可梦。它是带枪的宝可梦。
And they're just, I think they're also just really aggressive, you know, looking, you know, you could actually catch people in the Pokeballs and sell them. So it's basically crazy, much more like Mad Max. It's Mad Max meets Pokemon. It's a great idea of a theme. This article is really interesting patrick actually found this
而且它们只是，我觉得它们看起来也真的很激进，你知道，你可以真的用精灵球抓住人并卖掉他们。所以它基本上很疯狂，更像是《疯狂的麦克斯》。它是《疯狂的麦克斯》遇见《宝可梦》。这是一个很棒的主题创意。这篇文章真的很有趣，实际上是 Patrick 找到的。
um and it's it's it's claiming that a lot of the assets are ai generated um but they have no hard evidence and so i guess you know there's really like two things that i took away from this you know one is that you know the generative AI is really, you know, here to stay. It's not going anywhere. You know, I mean, the days of downloading like 30 gigabytes of MP3s when you buy a game, I feel like those days are very short lived. I think even if you did hire a voice actor, you know know you almost certainly want to do some type of capture of their voice and and if nothing else just to reduce the storage costs and you know generate their voice dynamically um so that's definitely here and then the other thing is
嗯，它声称很多资产是 AI 生成的，但他们没有确凿的证据。所以我想，你知道，我从中得出了两点结论。一是生成式 AI 确实已经存在了，它不会消失。我的意思是，当你买游戏时下载 30GB MP3 的日子，我觉得那些日子非常短暂。我想即使你确实雇佣了配音演员，你也几乎肯定想对他们的声音进行某种捕捉，至少为了减少存储成本，并动态生成他们的声音。所以这绝对已经存在了。然后另一件事是，
you know it's amazing that they they don't know because you know i've seen a lot of papers and other um you know reports where you can see how something is is generated by an ai um but but i guess you know they have a point that it's really hard to prove it um you know i i think um the examples I saw were interesting. Like, for example, if you see a, and this isn't a pal world thing, but if you see a picture of a face and the earrings don't match, you know, if it's a woman's face or man's face, anyone's face and the earrings, you know, they're wearing earrings and they don't match. That's a sign that it's generative AI because it's hard for the AI to, um, to, to get that symmetry. Right.
你知道，令人惊讶的是他们不知道，因为我见过很多论文和其他报告，你可以看出某样东西是如何由 AI 生成的。但我猜他们说得对，这真的很难证明。你知道，我认为我看到的例子很有趣。例如，如果你看到一个——这不是《幻兽帕鲁》的事情——但如果你看到一张人脸，耳环不匹配，你知道，如果是女性或男性的脸，任何人的脸，他们戴着耳环，但它们不匹配。这是一个它是生成式 AI 的迹象，因为 AI 很难获得那种对称性，对吧？
Um, but, um, but, but, you know, they haven't really found anything like this here. And it might be just that the person is,
嗯，但是，但是，你知道，他们在这里并没有真正发现任何类似的东西。可能只是那个人，
you know, starting with, uh, an AI model and then just as inspiration, but then putting a human touch on it and it makes it very hard to to track so okay a couple things uh if you're going to commit a crime put on mismatched earrings and like do all the tips that are generative so if someone captures you on the camera you can be like that's clearly not me because it's like clearly an ai so i i sense a trend where people people do this uh second second a hat tip here to ace rola uh is role does a youtube video on shaders actually uh anyways and on twitter oh x is where
你知道，从一个 AI 模型开始，然后只是作为灵感，但随后加上了人类的润色，这使得它很难追踪。所以，好吧，几件事。如果你要犯罪，戴上不匹配的耳环，做所有生成式 AI 的提示，这样如果有人在摄像头上拍到你，你可以说那显然不是我，因为它显然是 AI。所以我感觉到一种趋势，人们会这样做。第二，向 Ace Rola 致敬。Ace Rola 实际上做了一个关于着色器的 YouTube 视频，无论如何，在 Twitter 上——哦，X 是我第一次看到这种争议出现的地方。但如果你从未看过他的视频，去看看，Ace Rola。然后，是的，我觉得 Jason 说得对，他说，等等，首先，这重要吗？如果是生成式 AI 与否？答案是也许，这有点进入了那些灰色地带。如果它很有趣，它就很有趣。但与此同时，有人试图在工艺上投入工作，对吧？这回到了那个辩论，我不认为有一个单一的答案，但你知道，宜家家具和，我听说，真正的木制家具之间的区别。它们都是家具，但你可以长篇大论地谈论每种家具的各种优缺点。所以我认为最终，你知道，我不知道他们是否
where i sort of first saw this uh controversy rising up um but if you've never checked out checked out uh him check it out ace rola um and then yeah i i think jason's right he's like wait first of all does it matter like if it's generative ai or not and the answer is maybe and it's sort of you know gets into one of those gray areas if it's fun it's fun but at the same time there are people trying to put work into the craft right it goes back to that debate which you know i don't think there's there is an singular answer to but you know the difference between ikea furniture and you know i heard anderson real wood you know piece of furniture they're both furniture but you know you could kind of talk at length about you know various pros or cons of each and so i think in the end you know as i don't know that even they
必须坦诚或诚实地说明他们做了什么，他们只是，你知道，可能不应该到处声称这是高雅艺术，或者你知道，他们以某种方式，你知道，背后有很多人，对吧？如果你试图说，嘿，你应该支持这个游戏，因为这花了很多功夫，而实际上并没有，那么，你知道，这就像一个道德问题。但就目前而言，只要，如果我认为现在他们什么都没说，他们只是不说话。这已经成为一种一夜之间的轰动，所以我个人，是的，这很有趣，但我不知道我对此有什么具体的问题。是的，我觉得作为一个程序员，很难产生共鸣，对吧？
have to be forthright or honest about what they did they just you know probably shouldn't go around claiming that it's high art or you know that that you know they somehow that there's you know tons of people behind it right if you tried to say hey you should support this game because this took a lot of work and it didn't then you know there's like a sort of ethics problem but as far as you know as long as if i think right now they're not saying anything they're just just not talking uh it's you know been a kind of overnight sensation then i i personally yeah it's kind of interesting but i don't know that i have a specific problem with it. Yeah, I think as a coder, it's hard to really relate, right?
就像我们在开源项目上所做的所有代码，你知道，在我的例子中，比如 Eternal Terminal 和 MameHub 以及所有这些东西，它们都是公共仓库。所以，你知道，AI 正在扫描这些并使用它们来构建 GitHub Copilot 和所有这些东西，对吧？所以从某种意义上说，它们都是公共仓库，所以你知道 AI 正在扫描这些并使用它们来构建 GitHub
Like all of our code that we've done on open source, you know, like in my case like Eternal Terminal and MameHub and all these things, they're all public repos and so, you know, AI is scanning those and using them to build GitHub Copilot and all these things, right? So in a way, they're all public repos and so you know ai is scanning those and using them to build github
Copilot 和所有这些东西，对吧？所以从某种意义上说，它们有点像是在抄袭我，但这没关系，因为我反正也是从 Stack Overflow 抄的。所以，嗯，嗯，但是，但是，你知道，艺术家们并没有这种感觉。但这不真实。但这不真实。但如果我不是，我不是艺术家，所以我不能权威地发言。但当人们学习时，汲取灵感、练习抄袭并理解制作绘画需要什么，这是非常普遍的。抄袭太多不好，但衍生是可以的。
copilot and all these things right so in a way they're kind of like copying it from me but it's okay because i copied it from stack overflow anyway um so uh uh but but but you know artists don't don't feel the same way. But that's not true. But that's not true. But if I'm not, I'm not an artist, so I can't speak authoritatively. But it's very common when people are learning to take inspiration, to practice copying and to understand what it takes, you know, to make the paintings of paintings. And it's not good to copy too much, but to be derivative.
或者你甚至可以看到艺术家如何建立在其他艺术家的概念之上并扩展它们，并以某种方式推动它们前进的谱系。所以，在剽窃，你知道，宝可梦角色之间有一条非常细的界限。虽然如果你看看其他地方，比如数码宝贝，有很多数码宝贝怪物看起来非常相似，同样的喧嚣并没有得到那种……也许有，我可能太年轻了，不记得了。但，你知道，我不知道，有很多音乐也是这样，对吧？每个人都在从彼此那里汲取即兴重复段和想法，而且，你知道，最近有法院案件，我不知道答案，它听起来确实
Or you can even see sort of the lineage of how artists build on other artists concepts and extend them and sort of push them forward and so there's this very fine line between ripping off you know uh pokemon characters although if you look other places like digimon there's a lot of you know digimon monsters that look very similar and the same kind of brouhaha didn't get that real maybe it did I was probably too young um to remember but uh you know it I don't know there's a lot of music it's the same way right everyone's sort of taking riffs and ideas and from each other and it's you know there's been court cases recently where it's I don't know the answer it sure sounds
非常相似，但话又说回来，你知道，它听起来不错。如果你只是坐在那里播放音乐，直到你找到好听的东西，你可能会演奏出别人之前已经想出来的东西。所以，是的。是的。我的意思是，这也许是——我正在努力想在说这个之前是否有其他例子，但我真的不这么认为。我的意思是，假设这一切都是 AI 生成的，有人基本上把所有的宝可梦角色
really similar but then again you know it, it's a nice sounding thing. If you just sit there and play music until you find something nice, you may play something that someone else has already figured out before. So, yeah. Yeah. I mean, this is maybe, I'm trying to think if there's other examples before I say this, but I don't really think so. I mean, let's say this is all ai generated somebody basically threw all the pokemon characters
有史以来所有的都扔进了一些 AI 模型，现在他们能够吐出更多的宝可梦角色。你知道，这真的是我们第一次看到一些巨大的商业成功来自于某种生成式 AI 的东西。就像，你知道，人们非常担心，你知道，
over of all time into some ai model and now they're able to spit out more pokemon characters um you know this is really the first time where we've seen like some huge commercial success come out of some generative AI thing. Like, you know, like people are so worried about, you know,
虚假的东西，就像，你在试图冒充一个政治家之类的。嗯，但这，
fake, fake things like, like you're, you're trying to impersonate a, you know, a politician or something like that. Um, but this is,
你知道，并不是真的那样。我的意思是，你知道，就动机而言，并不是为了冒充宝可梦。动机实际上恰恰相反，是为了生成一些具有合理推诿性（plausible deniability）的东西，即它来自宝可梦。我的意思是，是的，有多少应用在 App Store 上，有多少《Flappy Bird》但带有，你知道，
you know, not really that, I mean, you know, in terms of like the, the incentive is not to impersonate Pokemon. The incentive is actually the opposite it's to generate something that has plausible deniability that it came from pokemon i mean yeah how many go on the app store how many flappy bird but with a you know
哦，太真实了，对吧？就像你说的，但对于 Jason 的观点，那些并没有经历那种商业成功。我看到的数字对于有多少人买了这款游戏来说绝对是疯狂的。我还没买，我很心动，因为它看起来确实很搞笑。但，是的，我的邻居们实际上要去玩它，所以我感到有点被迫去买它。好吧，好吧，从这个话题硬转弯，我在这里找到了一篇博客文章，这是一种旨在，我甚至不知道该怎么称呼它，不是模因，也不是带有图像宏或任何粘贴在上面的图片，而只是一种流传的模因，这是一种确定数字是奇数还是偶数的绝对愚蠢的方法。所以我链接了这里的博客，博客的标题说，
oh so true right like and you but to jason's point those don't experience the sort of commercial success the numbers i've seen are absolutely crazy for how many people have bought this guy i haven't bought it yet uh i'm tempted because it actually does look hilarious uh but uh yeah my neighbors are actually going to going to play it so i'm feeling kind of compelled to buy it all right well hard pivoting off of this one i found a blog article here which is something that's meant as sort of i don't even know how to call it not a meme and like a picture with an image macro or whatever pasted over top of it but just a sort of meme like going around which is kind of absolutely silly ways to solve determining whether a number is even or odd and so i linked the link the blob here the title of the blog it says the
博客的名字叫 Blabbing，但这是我在这个博客上看到的唯一一篇文章。所以，嗯，我想是一个新博客。但无论如何，链接将会在节目说明中。但这个人说，他们在 TikTok 上看到有人被喷了，这再次说明，我不在 TikTok 上，所以我现在只能通过第三手消息，但被喷是因为他们说他们通过基本上是一堆 if-else 语句来确定数字是奇数还是偶数。所以如果数字是 1，奇数；如果数字是 2，那是偶数；如果数字是 3，那是奇数。我已经搞砸了。大多数人会说，哦，你只是使用模运算符，如果你知道什么是模运算符的话，或者，哦，你使用，你知道，位运算，与，你知道，第一个最低有效位只是 1，然后那会告诉你，对吧？有很多种方法可以进行这种检查。
blog's name is blabbing but this is the only post i saw on on this blog so uh i think a new blog but anyways the link is uh will be in the show notes um but this person was saying they saw on tiktok someone get kind of ripped which again i'm not on tiktok so i i can't this third hand at this point but uh getting ripped for saying that they determined if a number is even or odd by basically a bunch of if else statements so if number is one odd if number is two that's even if number is three that's odd i'm gonna get messed it up already. Most people would say, Oh, do you just use a modulus operator, if you know what a modulus operator is, or, oh, you use, you know, bitwise, and with the, you know, first least significant bit just being one, and then that'll tell you, right, there's like a number of ways to kind of
大多数人会期望作为对你语言知识的测试，至少知道什么是模运算符或位掩码，取决于上下文。但这个人决定，在博客中决定自己承担这个任务，对于 32 位数字，也就是 40 亿个不同的数字，写 if 语句。有趣的部分，也是我提到它的原因，首先只是它的荒谬性。他们决定用 C 语言编写，起初听起来像是有些讽刺的理由。但他们所做的，这实际上是一件值得学习的有趣事情，而且，你知道，在比 40 亿行程序简单得多的程序上，自动生成所有的 if 语句，这样他们就可以产生那种输出。这需要什么？这是一项有用的技能，因为有时，做那个，而不是那个，而是其他代码生成，编写代码来生成代码是非常有用的。那没成功，C 编译器不喜欢
do this check. And most people would be expected as like a test of your language knowledge to know what the modulus operator is at minimum or bit masking, depending on the context. But this person decided to in the blog decided to take it on themselves to for 32 bit number, which is 4 billion different numbers, right if statements and the interesting part and the reason I bring it up is first just the absurdity of it. They decided to write it in C with what I sort of sounds like some tongue in cheek justification initially. But what they did, which is an actual interesting thing to learn to do and, you know, on simple program far simpler than a four billion line program to generate all of the if statements automatically um and that way they you know could produce that output and what does that take which is a useful skill to be able to know how to do because there are times when uh doing not that but other code generation writing code to make code is very useful that didn't work the compiler c compiler didn't like
那么多行，所以它决定输出原始汇编，并且确实让它工作了。我猜它说性能非常好。如果你仔细想想，它几乎就是一个巨大的查找表，你可以，有跳转表，所以你可以基本上跳转到一个设定的偏移量。所以如果你知道每个 if-else 语句是两个字节，并且你有一个非常聪明的汇编器或什么的，你可以基本上跳转到一个设定的偏移量。所以如果你知道每个 if-else 语句是两个字节，并且你有一个非常聪明的汇编器或什么的，你可以基本上跳转，你知道，基于数字，那个内存偏移量乘以 2 或其他什么。所以我可以想象它非常非常高效。然后只是有一个表，它要么输出 0 要么输出 1。但，是的，所以他们确实设法制作了他们说可以工作的汇编。当然，这是一个，我猜我们可以算出一个大约 4GB 的文件，所以它就像遗传
that many lines so then it decided to output raw assembly and actually did get it to work and i guess said it was very performant if you think about it i it's almost just a big lookup table and you can just there are jump tables so you can just basically jump to a set offset so if you know each if else statement is two bytes and you had a very clever assembler or whatever you can just basically jump to a set offset. So if you know each if else statement is two bytes and you had a very clever assembler or whatever, you could just jump, you know, based on the number that many,
可执行文件，40GB，荒谬之处在于，这当然是——我不想说这是一种确定数字是奇数还是偶数的非常愚蠢的方法，但这实际上导致了一些有趣的计算机科学练习。做这个，然后当然人们回应说，你能为 64 位数字做吗？答案是不能。是的，我喜欢这个，这个人的博客里只有这一篇文章，这没关系。当你有一个很酷的想法并想向人们展示时，你得发点什么。我不会责怪他们。不，是的，不，我的意思不是讽刺，我真的喜欢这个人，你知道，这不是 10 条关于“雇佣我”或自我吹嘘之类的文章，只是字面上说，这是我做的这件很酷的事情，砰，博客。不过我要说，这很难超越。所以我不知道你发第几篇
you know, memory offsets times two or whatever. So I could imagine it being very, very efficient. And then just having a table where it either outputs zero or one. But yeah, so they actually did manage to make assembly that they say works. Of course it's a, I guess we could figure out four gigabyte file roughly um so it's like genetic
二。那是真的。是的，我的意思是，你真的不能只是开始一个新博客。已经一个月了，他还没发帖。嗯，那太棒了。嗯，好吧。我的下一个新闻是 Seamless M4T。你见过这个吗，Patrick？不，没有。这东西简直太疯狂了。这就是我用来翻译这期节目的工具。所以如果你还没这样做，去 programmingthrowdown.com。取决于很多因素，
executable um 40 gigabyte ridiculous in that like there this is of course the i don't want to say this is a very silly way to solve whether a number is even or odd um but actually leads to some some kind of interesting uh computer science uh exercises and doing this and then of course people responded can you do it for 64-bit numbers and the answer is no yeah i love how this uh this this is the only post in this person's blog that's okay you gotta post something up when you have a cool idea and you want to show people like i i don't fault them no yeah no i mean i i didn't mean that sarcastic me i literally love that this person you know it's not like 10 posts about like like hire me or like self-aggrandizing or any of that just literally like here's this cool thing that i did boom blog i will say though that's like a tough act to follow. So I don't know what you make post number
最新的那一期可能没有这个。只要回到上一期。你可以用普通话听我们说话，所以这简直太疯狂了。所以基本上它的工作方式是，它进行语音转文本。现在，你必须为每个人准备一个单独的文件，你必须有一种分离的方法，或者在我们的例子中，你知道，我们有，你知道，我们节目中每个人都有一个单独的 MP3。但，你知道，它将其转换为文本，然后将文本翻译成其他语言，然后它从那种语言的文本转换成，你知道，他们为每种语言准备的几种声音之一。所以他们称之为“无缝”（seamless）的原因是，我不认为它是端到端学习的，但它可能是。
two. That's true. Yeah. I mean, you really can't just start a new blog. It's been a month now and he hasn't made a post. Um, that is awesome. Um, all right. My next news is Seamless M4T. Have you seen this, Patrick? No, uh-uh. This thing is freaking wild. So this is what I use to translate the episode. So if you haven't done this yet, go to programmingthrowdown.com. Depending on a bunch of factors,
但，你知道，它是独立的模块。但 API 和所有这些都非常简单。我的意思是，你基本上只是说，这是音频，我想得到文本，或者我想机器人化。嗯，那真的很有趣。嗯，然后，我开始选择其他语言。所以，嗯，这太神奇了。我的意思是，它是免费的，这太神奇了。它是完全开源的。任何人都可以使用它。嗯，我实际上在几个月前的黑色星期五买了一个 16，GPU，16GB 显存，这是运行这个模型所需的最低配置。但如果你没有那个，也没关系。我还让它在 Google Cloud Platform 上运行，
the very latest episode might not have this. Just go back an episode. And you can listen to us in mandarin chinese so it's it's totally freaking wild so basically the way this works is it um it does the uh speech to text now like you have to have a separate file for each person you have to have a way of separating or in our case you know we have um you know we have a separate mp3 for each person on the show um but you know it converts that to text and then it translates the text to other languages and then it goes from that language's text to, you know, one of several voices that they have for each language. And so the reason why they're calling it seamless is I don't think that it's end-to-end learned, but it might be.
你每小时支付大约 50 美分，我想，去租用其中一个。是的，非常合理。你甚至现在，他们有某种功能，如果它闲置了几个小时，它会自动关闭。所以你不必担心忘记它，而在月底收到 500 美元的账单之类的。
But, you know, it is separate sort of modules. But the API and all of that is extremely simple. I mean, you basically just say, here's audio, and I want to get back text, or I want to robot us. Um, that was really entertaining. Um, and then, uh, I started picking other languages. So, um, this is amazing. I mean, it's amazing that it's free. Um, it's totally open source. Anyone can use it. Um, I actually bought for black Friday a few months ago, a 16, uh, GPU at 16 gigs of VRAM, that's the bare minimum you need to run this model. But if you don't have that, it's totally fine. I also got this to run on Google Cloud Platform,
所以，是的，所有这些都非常方便。所以你可以在 Google Cloud 上运行它。还有 Google Colab。你可以在 Google Cloud 上运行它，那里也有 Google Colab，你可以在那里运行它。那里有一些 16GB 显存的 GPU，我不知道免费计划是否有效，但嗯，付费计划每月只需 10 美元。所以，是的，看看这个，我的意思是，它太神奇了。我会说，有两种模式，批处理模式和流式模式。批处理模式将所有内容加载到内存中，所以，你知道，你真的只能用它处理 10 秒的文件之类的。嗯，你知道，流式模式才是重点。文档仍然非常初步。我发现非常有用的东西是，他们在 NeurIPS 上做了一个教程，
and you pay about 50 cents an hour, I think, to rent one of those. Yeah, very reasonable. You can even now now they have something where if it's idle for so many hours, it shuts itself off. So you don't have to worry about forgetting about it and getting a $500 bill or something at the end of the month.
这是一个 AI 会议。他们做了一个关于 Seamless M4T 的完整教程，你可以免费观看视频并跟随学习，就像你在会议现场一样。我能够找到那个。所以去看看。看看这个教程。我觉得这真的处于某种超级令人兴奋的前沿。我正在研究，你知道，我们可以克隆我们的声音吗？因为如果我们能，如果它能是普通话，但听起来像我们，那会更好。这就像一个，Deepfake，你的耳环匹配，它会像 Deepfake Jason，但，是的，说普通话。所以如果，在几个月后，你可能会听到 Patrick 和我用普通话说话，也许我们会为了好玩换掉一期节目，看看人们是否注意到。我希望人们
So yeah, all of that is super convenient. So you can run it on Google Cloud. There's also Google Colab. You can run it on google cloud there's also google colab um you can run it there there's some 16 uh gig vram gpus there i don't know if the free plan would work but um the paid plan is only 10 bucks a month um so yeah check this out i mean it's amazing i will say that the there's two modes there's a batch mode and a streaming mode the batch mode loads everything into memory so you know you can really only use it for like a 10 second file or something like that um you know the streaming mode is really where it's at um the documentation is still pretty nascent. What I found really useful was they gave a tutorial at NeurIPS,
所以，这一切都非常方便。你可以在 Google Cloud 上运行它。还有 Google Colab，你也可以在那里运行。那里有一些 16GB 显存的 GPU，我不知道免费计划是否可行，但付费计划每月只需 10 美元。所以，去看看吧，这真的很棒。我想说的是，它有两种模式：批处理模式和流式模式。批处理模式会将所有内容加载到内存中，所以你实际上只能用它处理 10 秒左右的文件。流式模式才是真正的核心所在。文档目前还比较初级。我觉得非常有用的资源是他们在 NeurIPS 上提供的教程，
which is an AI conference. They did a whole tutorial on Seamless M4T, and you can watch the video and follow along as if you were at the conference for free. I was able to find that. So check it out. Check out this tutorial. I feel like this is really on the vanguard
那是一个人工智能会议。他们针对 Seamless M4T 做了一个完整的教程，你可以免费观看视频并跟着练习，就像亲临会议现场一样。我找到了那个视频，所以去看看吧，看看这个教程。我觉得这确实处于某种非常令人兴奋的前沿领域。
of something super exciting. I'm looking into, you know, can we clone our voices? Because if we could actually, if it could be Mandarin Chinese, but it sounds like us, that would be even better. It's like a, deep boy your earrings match it's gonna be like the deep fake jason but yeah speaking mandarin yeah so if uh in a few months you might hear patrick and i in mandarin maybe we'll swap out an episode just for fun and see if people notice i hope people
我正在研究我们是否可以克隆自己的声音。因为如果我们能做到这一点，如果它能用普通话表达，但听起来像我们，那就更好了。就像是深度伪造的杰森在说普通话。所以，几个月后，你们可能会听到我和帕特里克说普通话。也许我们会为了好玩替换掉一期节目，看看人们是否会注意到，我希望人们能注意到。
notice uh no no an old an old episode oh i see i see i see um you know i people focus like the machine learning stuff on the you know open ai and and i understand why um and the the sort of approach to agi i guess like you general intelligence. But I you're right, there's a lot of stuff happening, like out in the call it periphery that feels like we're really moving forward, especially once we start combining some of these things. So there's been a long work separating back speakers, people say they can't tell the difference between us. So I don't know, maybe that'll have to be like gen two of that, but you know, having a single file, separating it back and then, you know, running it through the system and combining it. But, but also, you know, we've
注意，呃，不，不，这是一个旧的，一个旧的剧集，哦，我明白了，我明白了，我明白了，嗯，你知道，人们关注像机器学习这类东西，比如 OpenAI，我理解为什么，嗯，还有关于 AGI 的那种方法，我想是通用人工智能。但是你是对的，有很多事情正在发生，比如在所谓的边缘领域，感觉我们确实在向前迈进，特别是当我们开始结合其中一些东西的时候。所以，长期以来一直有关于分离背景说话者的工作，人们说他们分不清我们。所以我不知道，也许那必须是第二代技术，但你知道，拥有一个单一文件，将其分离，然后，你知道，通过系统运行并将其组合。但是，但是，你知道，我们
not, I don't know that we've talked about it, but the sort of, um, nerfs and Gaussian splatting around like making 3d models from, you know, pictures. And right now they need kind of a lot of pictures of a specific kind, but you know, that'll get progress as well and then you can imagine the the sort of stable diffusion feeding into those things like there's like a lot of interesting sort of like one two iteration away um and and you know probably requiring some leaps there because it's not sort of like gluing normal software together but uh yeah there's a lot of exciting stuff happening that I think gets missed for the focus on LLMs. Yeah, I actually am more excited about diffusion models and LLMs.
不，我不知道我们是否讨论过它，但是，嗯，关于从图片制作 3D 模型的神经辐射场（NeRFs）和高斯溅射（Gaussian splatting）。目前它们需要特定类型的很多图片，但你知道，这也会取得进展，然后你可以想象稳定扩散（stable diffusion）模型输入到这些东西中，就像有很多有趣的东西，距离迭代一两次就差不多了，嗯，而且你知道，可能需要一些飞跃，因为它不像把普通软件粘在一起，但是，是的，有很多令人兴奋的事情正在发生，我认为因为关注大语言模型（LLMs）而被忽略了。是的，我实际上对扩散模型比对大语言模型更感兴趣。
We should do it. We should do a whole show on diffusion models. All right. Well, we know a person who probably speak to that. It's not me. Yeah, I was wondering if we knew a third person, but, but yeah,
我们应该做一期。我们应该专门做一期关于扩散模型的节目。好吧，我们认识一个人，他可能能谈谈这个。那不是我。是的，我还在想我们是否认识第三个人，但是，是的，
you know, have you seen the diffusion model with bomber man? No. Yeah. So basically, okay, let me just do a really quick and then we'll, we'll dedicate a show to this.
你知道，你看过那个用炸弹人（Bomberman）做的扩散模型吗？没有。是的，所以基本上，好吧，让我快速说一下，然后我们，我们将专门做一期节目来讨论这个。
The way diffusion models work is you have a bunch of references. So in the case of Mario or bomberberman or any of these games, you have levels that were created by humans, right? That's your reference. And you want to create more of those, right? So what you do is you corrupt the references, in this case, the Bomberman levels. You corrupt them, but the way you corrupt them references in this case the bomberman levels you corrupt them but you're
扩散模型的工作方式是你有一堆参考资料。所以以马里奥或炸弹人或任何这些游戏为例，你有由人类创建的关卡，对吧？那是你的参考。你想创造更多这样的关卡，对吧？所以你所做的是破坏这些参考资料，在这个例子中是炸弹人关卡。你破坏它们，但是你破坏它们的方式
the way you corrupt them is reversible so whatever you do you know the way the exact way to undo it and then you train a model to reverse the corruption all right and then once you have that model trained you give that model like random noise like levels that are complete garbage and you just tell it to reverse the corruption and you tell it to do it again and again and again and you tell it to reverse the corruption until it gets stuck in a cycle um when it gets stuck in a cycle you say it's done and uh and that's your bomber main level. It does. And it does.
你破坏它们的方式是可逆的，所以无论你做什么，你知道撤销它的确切方法，然后你训练一个模型来逆转这种破坏，好了，一旦你训练好了那个模型，你就给那个模型像随机噪声一样的东西，比如完全是垃圾的关卡，你只是告诉它逆转这种破坏，你告诉它一遍又一遍地做，你告诉它逆转这种破坏，直到它陷入循环，嗯，当它陷入循环时，你说它完成了，嗯，这就是你的炸弹人关卡。它确实做到了。而且它确实做到了。
It, it should have guarantees on like playability, like not having like something you can't reach or. So. It doesn't, you know, it's, it's all just AI. So there's no guarantees of anything.
它，它应该对可玩性有保证，比如不会出现你无法到达的地方或者。所以。它没有，你知道，这，这全都是人工智能。所以没有任何保证。
You'd, you'd have to do some fine tuning afterwards, but, but it's like scarily like true to form you know like uh yeah i can't remember if they if they um i can't remember if they wrote something to throw out the levels you know like they wrote basically a validator and throw out all the bad levels or if they just like you know they they didn't actually make a real game with it. It was a research paper. So they might have not bothered to do that.
你必须在之后进行一些微调，但是，但是它非常可怕地忠实于原版，你知道，比如，呃，是的，我不记得他们是否，他们，嗯，我不记得他们是否写了什么东西来丢弃那些关卡，你知道，比如他们基本上写了一个验证器，丢弃了所有糟糕的关卡，或者他们只是，你知道，他们实际上并没有用它制作一个真正的游戏。那是一篇研究论文。所以他们可能没有费心去做那个。
But you see the levels. It's like, yeah, that looks pretty cool. Like I could see how that could be kind of a fun Bomberman level. We just did it for the diffusion. But I guess like there's like some randomness that goes into how you select each operation. So I guess almost like backtracking you could just naively get towards the end and sort of try to go back and and you know assign some attempts or whatever and you know oh this you know do a validation at the end like did i
但是你看到了那些关卡。就像，是的，看起来很酷。就像我能看出那可能是一个有趣的炸弹人关卡。我们只是为了扩散模型才这么做的。但我猜，在选择每个操作时会有一些随机性。所以我猜几乎就像回溯一样，你可以天真地走到最后，然后尝试回去，你知道，分配一些尝试之类的，你知道，哦，这个，你知道，在最后做一个验证，比如我
get a good level did i get a you know validatable level yep yep yeah exactly oh man it's gonna be cool the future is scary we're going to be out of jobs. The future is super scary. I mean, I definitely wouldn't want to be in the games industry. I mean, as an engineer, you would be fine. But if you are a concept artist or a voice actor or something like that, I mean, it's going to be different.
得到了一个好的关卡吗？我得到了一个，你知道，可验证的关卡吗？是的，是的，是的，完全正确。哦天哪，这会很酷。未来很可怕，我们将要失业了。未来超级可怕。我的意思是，我绝对不想进入游戏行业。我的意思是，作为一名工程师，你会没事的。但如果你是一名概念艺术家或配音演员之类的，我的意思是，情况会不同。
There are some heads of studios and stuff coming out and basically forecasting like reduced need for a lot of those things um people talking about you know for doing like cold calling and sales calls and informational sessions you know maybe reduced need for folks there um and then you know also some places are getting flooded there's always been a sort of like low bar kindle book ebook you know coloring book drawing just like you know low effort sort of written word kind of stuff and all of that too i think is uh this ai stuff is sort of competing with not the you know top tier stuff but the sort of like low tier low effort people turning those out hoping one or two people buy them or whatever which has proven successful i think i think there's a
有一些工作室负责人之类的人出来，基本上预测对很多这类东西的需求会减少，嗯，人们谈论，你知道，进行冷呼叫和销售电话以及信息发布会，你知道，也许对那里的员工需求会减少，然后，你知道，有些地方也被淹没了，一直有一种低门槛的 Kindle 电子书，你知道，涂色书，绘画，就像，你知道，低努力程度的文字类东西，所有这些，我认为，嗯，这些人工智能东西正在与，不是，你知道，顶级的东西竞争，而是与那种低端、低努力程度的人制作的东西竞争，希望有一两个人买它们之类的，这已经被证明是成功的，我想，我认为有一个
threat to those not not that that's going to be a big problem but once they start targeting people who are you know higher up the the food chain there that's that's going to be a struggle and i will weirdly segue that into our book of the show from high quality books that are definitely not AI generated. That's right. So my first one, I tried, I might have recommended it before if I did. Well, it's worth a second recommendation. I tried looking, but after 171 shows, it's a bit of a process to try to search for it.
对那些东西的威胁，不是说那会是一个大问题，但一旦他们开始针对那些，你知道，食物链上层的人，那，那将是一场斗争，我会奇怪地过渡到我们的本期推荐书目，从绝对不是人工智能生成的优质书籍开始。没错。所以我的第一本，我试过了，我可能之前推荐过，如果我推荐过的话。好吧，值得第二次推荐。我试着找过，但在 171 期节目之后，要搜索它是一个过程。
And that is Foundation by Isaac Asimov, which is actually a many book series. And the first one is a great place to start. And recently, this became a TV show, which I think renewed some interest. The TV show doesn't follow the book super closely. But if you've never read some of the classic science fiction, it's really like a fascinating trip to see how close some of the stuff got from people writing long before, you know, computers were a thing, much less mobile phones. Some stuff is just like laughably wrong. And some stuff is just like, wow, that's eerily the same issues we're dealing with today. And so reading classic science
那就是艾萨克·阿西莫夫的《基地》，实际上是一个多卷系列。第一本是一个很好的起点。最近，这变成了一部电视剧，我认为这重新引起了一些兴趣。电视剧并没有非常紧密地遵循原著。但如果你从未读过一些经典的科幻小说，看到人们在电脑出现很久之前，更不用说手机了，写的东西有多接近，这真是一次迷人的旅程。有些东西简直是可笑的错误。而有些东西简直是，哇，那和我们今天处理的问题惊人地相似。所以阅读经典科幻
fiction is something worth doing if you've never tried it before and the foundation series is a i feel like a pretty formative uh series of science fiction and uh just to give people flavor since i've not said anything actually about the book is the idea is there's a an empire ruling the galaxy and um there's concern that that this uh this these people raise that the empire is is going to collapse and it's going to cause you know humanity basically to be set back and you know and really be a struggle and everyone's going to be bad off and so they've created a a sort of way to help shortcut that to make it better but of course the empire itself is very unhappy with this and the whole prediction that this was going to happen is this of course fake but it sounds very
小说如果你以前从未尝试过，是值得做的事情，而且《基地》系列是一个，我觉得是一个非常有影响力的科幻系列，嗯，为了给人们一点感觉，因为我实际上还没说关于这本书的任何事情，这个想法是有一个帝国统治着银河系，嗯，有人担心，这，这些人提出帝国将会崩溃，这将导致，你知道，人类基本上倒退，你知道，真的会是一场斗争，每个人都会过得很糟糕，所以他们创造了一种方法来帮助缩短这个过程，让它变得更好，但当然帝国本身对此非常不高兴，而且预测会发生这种情况的整个预测当然是假的，但它听起来非常
convincing psycho history which is this idea that you cannot predict individuals but that you know sort of like i think the analogy they use is like a gas you can predict a lot of statistics about gases even though an individual molecule in a gas is, is, you know, very, very difficult to predict. And so through that, they can kind of predict the course of human history and how things will go and make updates and help keep it on, you know, a plan that will, will, you know, sort of benefit the most humans. And it's just a very interesting read in the dynamics. And so if you've never read it before, and if that sounds at all interesting, although I probably did a poor pitch of it, or if you've watched a TV show and maybe didn't realize it was also a book,
令人信服，心理史学，这是这个想法，你不能预测个人，但你知道，就像，我想他们使用的类比就像气体，你可以预测关于气体的很多统计数据，即使气体中的单个分子，是，你知道，非常，非常难以预测。因此，通过这种方式，他们可以预测人类历史的进程以及事情将如何发展，并进行更新，帮助保持它在，你知道，一个将，将，你知道，某种程度上造福大多数人类的计划上。这只是一个关于动态的非常有趣的读物。所以如果你以前从未读过它，如果这听起来有任何意思，尽管我可能做了一个糟糕的推介，或者如果你看过电视剧，可能没意识到它也是一本书，
I'll pitch Foundation by Isaac Asimov. Yeah. Did you read it recently or is that when you read it? I read it actually as a teenager. So I read it a long time ago. Yeah. Same here. I have to confess, I don't remember that much of it, but I do remember having a big impression on me when I read it a long time ago. Yeah, same here. I have to confess, I don't remember that much of it, but I do remember having a big impression on me when I read it. I think I also had kind of forgotten I read it. And then I like looked up the sort of summary and it was like, oh, I remember.
我会推介艾萨克·阿西莫夫的《基地》。是的。你是最近读的，还是你读的时候？我实际上是十几岁时读的。所以我很久以前读过。是的，我也是。我必须承认，我不记得太多了，但我确实记得很久以前读它时给我留下了深刻的印象。是的，我也是。我必须承认，我不记得太多了，但我确实记得读它时给我留下了深刻的印象。我想我也忘了我读过它。然后我像查了一下总结，就像，哦，我记得了。
And then I actually have watched, I think there's a couple of seasons now of the TV show. And I will say, you know, it's a pretty dark, dark thing. So not watch with kids, but pursuing the same kinds of ideas. And I thought, I thought I like it, even though it doesn't follow the book that closely. It uses some of the concepts and the sort of setup to kind of examine some, some of different ideas, but in a similar sort of some similar vein. Cool. Yeah, definitely. If folks haven't read that, definitely give it a read. It's a great series. Um, my book of the show is propaganda by Edward Bernays. So this, uh, this is a fascinating
然后我实际上看了，我想现在有几季电视剧了。我会说，你知道，这是一个相当黑暗，黑暗的东西。所以不要和孩子们一起看，但追求的是同样的想法。我想，我想我喜欢它，尽管它没有那么紧密地遵循原著。它使用了一些概念和那种设置来检查一些，一些不同的想法，但在类似的，一些类似的脉络中。酷。是的，绝对。如果大家还没读过那个，一定要读一读。这是一个很棒的系列。嗯，我的本期推荐书目是爱德华·伯内斯的《宣传》。所以这个，嗯，这是一个迷人的
book. Um, it's, it's so wild that I almost, you know, I really, I wouldn't take it all as ground truth, really. I mean, a book about propaganda might be propaganda. You know, it's kind of like meta. get right into in the book is that is that um um and again this isn't my this is not my theory on life but that basically you know democracy can't work um and and so you really need to have just like a few few different ideas to follow that it can't just be a total free-for-all i mean a good example is the is the app store that patrick was talking about where there's like a million knockoffs like you could search pretty much any word in the dictionary and you're going to find a video game based on that word and they're all kind of cookie cutter and and there's no it's very hard to get
书。嗯，它，它太疯狂了，我几乎，你知道，我真的，我不会把所有内容都当作真理，真的。我的意思是，一本关于宣传的书本身可能就是宣传。你知道，这有点像元认知。书中直接切入的主题是，嗯，嗯，再说一次，这不是我的人生理论，而是基本上，你知道，民主行不通，嗯，所以你真的需要只有几个，几个不同的想法来遵循，它不能只是完全的自由放任。我的意思是，一个很好的例子是帕特里克谈到的应用商店，那里有数百万个仿制品，就像你可以搜索字典里的几乎任何单词，你都会找到一个基于那个单词的视频游戏，它们都是那种千篇一律的，而且没有，很难在
noticed in the app store or to find good content. And so you're really relying on the, you know, editor's picks. And so in a way, it's like you have this really democratic platform, but what it really degenerates to is just like a handful of editor's picks and folks who have a big audience already and all of that. And so the claim by the book, by the propaganda book is that, you know, there's just so much content and this was written a hundred years ago. 1928. Yeah.
应用商店中被注意到或找到好的内容。所以你真的依赖于，你知道，编辑精选。所以从某种意义上说，你拥有这个非常民主的平台，但它真正退化成的只是像少数几个编辑精选和那些已经拥有庞大受众的人等等。所以这本书，《宣传》这本书的说法是，你知道，内容实在太多了，而且这是 100 年前写的。1928 年。是的。
There's just, there's so many clubs that you could be a part of. There's just so much, so many choices, so many brands, so many of this, I mean that, that really propaganda is the way
有太多的俱乐部你可以加入。有太多的选择，太多的品牌，太多的这个，我的意思是，那，那确实宣传是
by which like 90 of your options get filtered out and you can just focus on the top 10 so it almost becomes like a um a way to ante in it's like okay you, you have to build this propaganda machine to be part of the system. And everyone who doesn't do that ends up just getting kind of lost, right? um some of them were pretty mind-blowing um yeah i won't spoil them but um maybe i'll spoil one there's there's this cigarette company that um they were under a lot of pressure there were a lot of moms who didn't want their uh sons and daughters smoking because they had heard about you know all these issues i don't know if lung cancer was a really known entity in the 1920s but but you know they they thought there were health issues and so they were able to like start up this like uh women's liberation march sponsored by marlborough and uh they basically tapped into the women's liberation movement of the 1920s as sort of like a back pressure, you know, against like this, like kind of like mothers against smoking group. And the whole thing is just blowing my mind.
通过它，你 90% 的选择被过滤掉，你可以只关注前 10%，所以它几乎变成了一种，嗯，一种入场方式，就像好的，你，你必须建立这个宣传机器才能成为系统的一部分。而所有不这样做的人最终都会迷失，对吧？嗯，其中一些非常令人震惊，嗯，是的，我不会剧透它们，但，嗯，也许我会剧透一个，有一个香烟公司，嗯，他们承受了很大的压力，有很多妈妈不想让她们的儿子和女儿吸烟，因为她们听说过，你知道，所有这些问题，我不知道肺癌在 1920 年代是否是一个真正已知的实体，但，但你知道，她们认为有健康问题，所以她们能够像发起这个，嗯，妇女解放游行，由万宝路赞助，她们基本上利用了 1920 年代的妇女解放运动作为一种反压力，你知道，对抗像这个，像母亲反对吸烟团体。整件事简直让我大开眼界。
I mean, it goes without saying that I think that's fair to say patrick and i are like what would you say is like task oriented in the sense like we don't we're not we're definitely not master manipulators uh we're not uh we're not like these kind of people um you know uh patrick doesn't even have a social media account i barely use my social media account um and so for me this is like a whole different dimension to you know humanity really um i mean it's something that i never would have really considered or thought of if i hadn't been recommended this book so i found it absolutely fascinating um highly recommend it uh very interesting yeah i think sometimes words get uh like artificially intense negative things so i think like some of these things
我的意思是，不用说，我认为公平地说，帕特里克和我，怎么说呢，是任务导向型的，意思是，我们不是，我们绝对不是操纵大师，我们不是，我们不是这种人，嗯，你知道，帕特里克甚至没有社交媒体账户，我几乎不使用我的社交媒体账户，所以对我来说，这就像是人类的一个完全不同的维度，真的，嗯，我的意思是，如果我没有被推荐这本书，我永远不会真正考虑或想到这一点，所以我发现它绝对迷人，嗯，强烈推荐它，嗯，非常有趣，是的，我认为有时词汇会，嗯，被人工地赋予强烈的负面含义，所以我认为像其中一些事情
you're saying the other one i'll kind of by analogy or by similarity talk about is politics so like people have i don't want politics in the office. It's like, well, you need to be aware regardless of whether you want to quote unquote play politics. Politics is a like human way of, you know, that things happen and decisions get made and,
你说的另一个，我会通过类比或相似性来谈论，那就是政治，所以人们有，我不想要办公室政治。就像，好吧，无论你是否想引用“玩弄政治”，你都需要意识到。政治是一种人类的方式，你知道，事情发生和决策制定的方式，以及，
you know, backdoor backroom decisions, you know, these kinds of, you have to be aware of them. If you, you know, want to kind of like at least
你知道，后门密室决策，你知道，这些种类的，你必须意识到它们。如果你，你知道，想要某种程度上
have some modicum of control over over what happens and i think by extension propaganda similar it's you know it has a very very negative tone to it but it i mean it's it's a way of lots of people doing stuff they may not see it as propaganda right they just see it as hey i'm trying to get my ideas across or find a way to make people more open to this um but sort of calling it out and putting a label on it saying how common it is is a way of sort of engaging with it yeah and it turns out actually the negative connotation to prop to the word propaganda is also propaganda so the word they actually talk about is the root of the word propaganda comes from the Catholic Church in like the 1600s had a like a part of seminary where they were kind of teaching priests and bishops and cardinals um about how to kind of spread uh catholicism and i think that's where the word actually comes from and then uh you know and then i think uh and
对发生的事情有一点点控制，我认为通过延伸，宣传也是类似的，它（你知道，它有一种非常非常负面的基调），但我的意思是，这是一种很多人做事情的方式，他们可能不认为这是宣传，对吧？他们只是认为，嘿，我正在尝试传达我的想法，或者找到一种方法让人们对这个更开放，但是某种程度上指出它并给它贴上标签，说它有多普遍，是一种与它互动的方式。是的，而且事实证明，实际上对“宣传”这个词的负面含义也是一种宣传，所以他们实际上谈论的词，宣传这个词的词根来自 1600 年代的罗马天主教会，他们有一个神学院的部分，他们在那里教导牧师、主教和红衣主教，关于如何传播天主教，我认为这个词实际上就是从那里来的，然后，嗯，你知道，然后我认为，嗯，而且
so at that time it had a positive connotation and i think it the connotation flipped over time as a society we got kind of like uh you know not happy with like proselytizing and then and then and then now it's like really like commercial propaganda and and all that um so yeah like the propaganda i think collided headfirst into the enlightenment and lost when it comes to you know reputation as a word um but yeah it's it's yeah, the book is totally mind-blowing. I highly recommend people read it. And to Patrick's point, and we talked about this in the marketing
所以在那个时候它有一个积极的含义，我认为随着时间的推移，含义发生了翻转，作为一个社会，我们变得有点，嗯，你知道，对传教不满意，然后，然后，现在它真的就像商业宣传，以及所有这些，嗯，所以是的，就像宣传，我认为它与启蒙运动正面碰撞并失败了，当谈到作为一个词的声誉时，但是的，它，是的，这本书完全令人大开眼界。我强烈建议人们读一读。而且对于帕特里克提到的观点，我们在营销
episode. We had an episode with a gentleman from marketing. I'll give you a really concrete example. I made that game AI Hero. I made it totally free. There know there's no ads there's no in-app purchases or anything like that um you know i told my friends and family about it all that and it has i didn't check recently but it has i think like 100 downloads or something like that
那一期讨论过这个。我们有一期节目请了一位来自营销界的绅士。我给你一个非常具体的例子。我制作了那个游戏 AI Hero。我把它做得完全免费。那里，你知道，没有广告，没有应用内购买之类的东西，嗯，你知道，我告诉了我的朋友和家人，所有这些，它有，我最近没查，但它有，我想大概 100 次下载之类的
um and now you know i made it you know to frank, I kind of made it for myself. I mean, so I'm not out there trying to get a bunch of downloads, but I was even still surprised that it got such, such, uh, such little notice. Um, and it really just doubles down on that point that, you know, you have to get a propaganda cycle going, a marketing cycle going for anything that you want to have mass appeal. Otherwise, there's just too much content out there. So, yeah, it's not a propaganda marketing. These aren't words that you should be afraid of. I'll say that it's not something that, at least I don't know about Patrick, but it's not something that I personally am very good at.
嗯，现在你知道，我制作它，你知道，坦白说，我有点为自己制作它。我的意思是，所以我不是在外面试图获得大量下载，但我仍然惊讶于它得到了如此，如此，如此少的关注。嗯，它真的加倍强调了这一点，你知道，你必须为你想要拥有大众吸引力的任何东西建立一个宣传周期，一个营销周期。否则，外面的内容实在太多了。所以，是的，这不是宣传营销。这些不是你应该害怕的词。我会说，这不是什么，至少我不知道帕特里克的情况，但这不是我个人非常擅长的东西。
It's definitely something where I try to partner with other people who are much better at it than I am. Um, but, uh, but it's something that, you know, I think we all should really appreciate. It is very important. If I did want AI hero to, to, to get, you know, a ton of people, you know, I would have to go about things very differently. I think I'd have to be posting regularly on Reddit. I'd have to figure out some way to maybe gin up some controversy. Maybe I'd make a fake post saying that it's generative AI, pretending to be somebody else attacking me for using generative AI. I don't know. But this is just from reading
这绝对是我尝试与比我擅长得多的人合作的事情。嗯，但是，嗯，这是，你知道，我认为我们都应该真正欣赏的事情。它非常重要。如果我确实想让 AI Hero，让，让，让一大堆人，你知道，我必须以非常不同的方式去做。我想我必须定期在 Reddit 上发帖。我必须想出某种方法来制造一些争议。也许我会发一个假帖子，说它是生成式人工智能，假装是别人攻击我使用生成式人工智能。我不知道。但这只是从阅读
the book. There's a million things you could do to amp up your thing, whatever it is. But if you don't do that, probably no one's going to pay attention. And that's true in politics. If you make a political party, nobody's really going to care. true in in in most things so so uh yeah it's just a fact of life yeah i think there's a lot to say here but but probably just uh move on for now as they get all right yeah moving forward so time for tool of the show all right what's your tool uh not a tool a game uh but uh classic patrick cop out mine is i've been getting into these recently but this is the one that i sort of encountered first which is the room this is pretty old at this point so most people probably played it before if not you know i would encourage you
这本书中得到的。你可以做一百万件事来放大你的东西，无论它是什么。但如果你不这样做，可能没人会注意。在政治中也是如此。如果你建立一个政党，没人会真正在意。在大多数事情中也是如此，所以，嗯，是的，这只是生活的事实。是的，我认为这里有很多话要说，但，但可能只是，嗯，现在继续前进，因为他们都，好的，是的，继续前进，所以是本期工具时间。好的，你的工具是什么？不是工具，是一个游戏，但，嗯，经典的帕特里克逃避问题，我的是，我最近开始接触这些，但这是我首先遇到的一个，那就是《The Room》。这在这一点上已经很老了，所以大多数人可能之前玩过，如果没有，你知道，我会鼓励你
to check one of them out often they're very cheap or free on sort of android ios i think there's a steam version probably a web version somewhere but the idea is basically uh kind of like an escape room in an app uh you know just like without without the time limit you're just like a series of puzzles um and you interact with them and for me i've actually never done an escape room uh why i i want to i just like it just hasn't been a thing that i've been able to do but i'm i'm sort of fascinated by the concept and these games are just like an easy way to spend a few minutes sort of playing with something and trying to figure it out i will say in the genre some games do it better or worse and i have my own particular sort of like i don't like
去看看其中一个，通常它们在 Android、iOS 上非常便宜或免费，我想有一个 Steam 版本，可能某个地方有一个网页版本，但这个想法基本上，嗯，有点像应用里的密室逃脱，你知道，就像没有，没有时间限制，你只是像一系列谜题，嗯，你与它们互动，对我来说，我实际上从未做过密室逃脱，为什么，我，我想做，我只是，它只是我一直没能做的事情，但我，我有点被这个概念迷住了，这些游戏只是像一种花几分钟时间玩弄某样东西并试图弄清楚它的简单方法。我会说在这个类型中，有些游戏做得更好或更差，我有我自己的特定，嗯，我不喜欢
things that are you're just supposed to try random stuff until they happen there should be some clue that you can look for and it can be obscure or it could be that you have to pay attention or whatever but sometimes they fall into like how was i supposed to know that like you know there's no indication that you're supposed to you know touch the top of the windowsill and like it's going to be movable uh it's like okay but sometimes you fall into this but anyways um i guess a pitch for these kinds of puzzle escape room games in general and there's there's many in the in the genre but um for me the first one that i sort of bumped into was the room series i think
那些你只是应该尝试随机的东西直到它们发生的事情，应该有一些你可以寻找的线索，它可以是模糊的，或者它可能是你必须注意之类的，但有时它们会陷入像“我怎么可能知道那个”之类的，你知道，没有任何迹象表明你应该，你知道，触摸窗台的顶部，就像它会是可移动的，嗯，就像好的，但有时你会陷入这种情况，但无论如何，嗯，我猜是对这类益智密室逃脱游戏的一个推介，在这个类型中有很多，但，嗯，对我来说，我首先碰到的第一个是《The Room》系列，我想
there's like now four or five in the series um but you know shout out to the the original one um and if you've never played one before uh you know check it out yeah totally i've played the room i think it's great a lot of fun um it taps into your common sense so yeah you do have some intuition into what the answer of the puzzle the answer to the puzzle is um my tool the show is also somewhat of a cop-out because we've had them on the show before we did in fact had a whole episode dedicated to incredibuild but you know i was building a new version of maimhub my house today, I guess, because it's like using all the desktops in the house. It's kind of the point of the tool. And I just thought
现在系列里有四五个了，但，你知道，向最初的那一个致敬，如果你以前从未玩过，你知道，去看看吧。是的，完全正确，我玩过《The Room》，我认为它很棒，很有趣，嗯，它利用了你的常识，所以是的，你确实对谜题的答案，谜题的答案是什么有一些直觉，我的本期工具也是某种程度上的逃避问题，因为我们之前在节目中介绍过它们，我们确实有一整期节目专门讨论 Incredibuild，但你知道，我今天正在构建 Maimhub 的一个新版本，我的房子，我想，因为它就像使用房子里的所有台式机。这有点像这个工具的重点。我只是想
to myself, man, this is such an amazing tool. I've used it for so many years for free. If you're using it for your home use, it's not for professional use, it's totally free. I felt like they deserve another shout out after so many years um we've gotten tons of emails from folks who have uh you know got their company to buy incredibuild and all of that so we have been able to drive some business to them which i'm really proud of um but yeah it's incredibuild if it basically the way it works is it hooks into your build system. It even has plugins for visual studio.
对自己说，伙计，这真是一个了不起的工具。我已经免费使用它很多年了。如果你在家里使用它，不是用于专业用途，它是完全免费的。我觉得在这么多年之后，他们值得再次被提及，嗯，我们收到了很多来自那些，你知道，让他们的公司购买 Incredibuild 的人的电子邮件，所有这些，所以我们已经能够为他们带来一些业务，我对此感到非常自豪，嗯，但是的，它是 Incredibuild，如果它基本上它的工作方式是它挂钩到你的构建系统中。它甚至有 Visual Studio 的插件。
So if you're building on visual studio, it works. Um, if not, it has, you know, it hooks into GCC and all that stuff. Um,
所以如果你在 Visual Studio 上构建，它有效。嗯，如果没有，它有，你知道，它挂钩到 GCC 和所有那些东西。嗯，
and you just, instead of, you know, choosing build solution from visual studio, you choose, you know, start Incredibuild. And,
你只是，而不是，你知道，从 Visual Studio 选择构建解决方案，你选择，你知道，启动 Incredibuild。而且，
uh, I have the Incredibuild agent running on all the desktops here in the house and they all just start the fans all start roaring and uh they all start working together to build stuff so maimhub takes i think like two and a half hours to build um but with incredibuild uh you know i can get it done in like 10 minutes or something. So it's super nice and highly recommend it. Very nice. Very nice. All right.
嗯，我在家里的所有台式机上都运行了 Incredibuild 代理，它们都开始，风扇都开始轰鸣，嗯，它们都开始一起工作来构建东西，所以 Maimhub 构建需要，我想大概两个半小时，但有了 Incredibuild，你知道，我可以在 10 分钟左右完成它。所以它超级好，强烈推荐它。非常好。非常好。好的。
Well, I think it's time for our topic, which is compilers and interpreters. Yeah, this is a request by Jessica W. I won't say your last name. I know some people might sense that. But thank you so much, Jessica, for this idea. It's a great one. All right. I didn't know, you know, Jason sort of bowed out of like, well, that's not my background. So it kind of fell to me. And I struggled a bit with the tack to take here because there's a there's a lot to be said. This is a big, you know, request. So I decided to take a stab at what i'll say is a
好吧，我认为是时候讨论我们的主题了，也就是编译器和解释器。是的，这是 Jessica W 的请求。我不会说你的姓氏。我知道有些人可能会感觉到。但非常感谢你，Jessica，提出这个想法。这是一个很棒的想法。好的。我不知道，你知道，Jason 某种程度上退出了，比如，嗯，那不是我的背景。所以它有点落到了我身上。我在这里采取的策略有点挣扎，因为有很多话要说。这是一个很大的，你知道，请求。所以我决定尝试一下我所说的
sampler you know kind of going through a bunch of different topics in the area um with some sort of high level overview but you know choosing a interpreted versus compiled language i guess you could say choosing a compiler versus interpreter but most of the time if you choose a language and the pros and cons of language you're sort of of choosing one of these for that. But then in each of these, there's just an incredible depth you can go into or not. You know, most of the time, I guess, we're big believers and, you know, the right tool for the job. So despite the fact that I may throw stones at Python, you know, a lot of times, you're only going to run an analysis once or, you know, it doesn't really even really matter how long it
采样器，你知道，有点浏览该领域的一堆不同主题，嗯，有一些某种高层概述，但，你知道，选择解释型语言还是编译型语言，我想你可以说选择编译器还是解释器，但大多数时候，如果你选择一种语言和语言的优缺点，你某种程度上是在为它选择其中之一。但随后在每一个中，都有令人难以置信的深度你可以深入研究或不深入研究。你知道，大多数时候，我猜，我们是坚定的信徒，你知道，适合工作的正确工具。所以尽管我可能会向 Python 扔石头，你知道，很多时候，你只会运行一次分析，或者，你知道，它甚至根本不重要它需要多长时间
takes. And so you can get this just really big worry about speed or performance or, you know, selecting exactly the best tool. But I will say, most of the programs I write are probably run less than a dozen times ever, even to check them in and put them in at work, you know, and you, I may run it a few times, someone else may use it, we may copy and paste the code around, but any given instances is just not not that and then, and then a very few are, you know, run hundreds of times every day. And you know, or 1000s of times, inner loops and calls and those ones. And so there's a really a really wide range and so um find a few things that you're you're sort of proficient in and i'll say a way of disclaimer
，所以你可以得到这个，只是非常担心速度或性能，或者，你知道，选择完全最好的工具。但我会说，我编写的大多数程序可能运行次数不到一打，甚至在工作时检查它们并放入它们，你知道，而且你，我可能会运行它几次，别人可能会使用它，我们可能会复制和粘贴代码，但任何给定的实例只是不是那样，然后，然后很少有，你知道，每天运行数百次。你知道，或者数千次，内部循环和调用以及那些。所以有一个非常，非常广泛的范围，所以，嗯，找到一些你，你某种程度上精通的东西，我会说一个免责声明
before we dive in here is just sort of like you'll see a lot of uh internet flame wars about you know oh that that's slow because it's a you know scripting or you know don't if you're going to build something in godot don't use as a gd script because it's you know it know, scripting or, you know, don't, if you're going to build something in Godot, don't use as a GD script because it's, you know, it's going to be slow and it's, I don't, I mean, if you're finding yourself in a problem and maybe you want to listen to some of that or being aware is good, but I feel a lot of people hesitate to take the first step and get what, you know, I'll call analysis paralysis, you know, from making a decision and actually better to just build something and let it suck and be slow and and introspect why at the end of getting somewhere with it and then and you're
在我们深入探讨之前，只是某种程度上，你会看到很多，嗯，互联网上的火焰战争，关于，你知道，哦，那个很慢，因为它是，你知道，脚本，或者，你知道，不要，如果你要在 Godot 中构建东西，不要使用 GD 脚本，因为它是，你知道，它，你知道，脚本，或者，你知道，不要，如果你要在 Godot 中构建东西，不要使用 GD 脚本，因为它是，你知道，它会很慢，而且，我不，我的意思是，如果你发现自己陷入了一个问题，也许你想听听其中的一些，或者意识到它是好的，但我感觉很多人在迈出第一步时犹豫不决，并得到什么，你知道，我会称之为分析瘫痪，你知道，从做出决定，实际上最好只是构建一些东西，让它烂，让它慢，并在最后弄清楚为什么，在它上面取得一些进展，然后，你
gonna make a follow-up choice than to never take the first step um yeah totally there's a balance there but okay off of my soapbox all right so i guess anytime we run a program we're talking about you know a processor and we were talking in the Christmas episode, holiday episode, Jason was mentioning, oh, now I already forgot if it was RISC-V or RISC-V. I think RISC-V. RISC-V. Yeah. Okay, good.
会做出后续选择，而不是永远不迈出第一步，嗯，是的，完全正确，那里有一个平衡，但好的，离开我的肥皂箱，好的，所以我猜任何时候我们运行一个程序，我们都在谈论，你知道，一个处理器，我们是在圣诞节那一期，假期那一期谈论的，Jason 提到，哦，现在我已经忘了是 RISC-V 还是 RISC-V。我想是 RISC-V。RISC-V。是的。好的，很好。
RISC-V. And RISC-V is an instruction set architecture, a sort of way of having computers run. And it has, I guess, what you would call machine code. So out of, you know, wherever it's loading the program, probably RAM, and then it sort of loads a set of bits, right? If it's a 64 bit processor, it loads, you know, 64 bits, and can kind of look through there. And part of that is the operation to perform in some instructions about to load it from a register or to load it from a place in memory or whatever. And then the processor sort of handles that.
RISC-V。而 RISC-V 是一种指令集架构，一种让计算机运行的方式。它有，我猜，你会称之为机器码的东西。所以从，你知道，无论它加载程序的地方，可能是 RAM，然后它某种程度上加载一组位，对吧？如果它是一个 64 位处理器，它加载，你知道，64 位，并且可以某种程度上查看那里。其中一部分是要执行的操作，一些关于从寄存器加载它或从内存中的某个地方加载它的指令，或者其他什么。然后处理器某种程度上处理那个。
And that is machine code. If you ever do like NAND to Tetris or there's another game where you build logic gates out of NAND on your web browser, or you take a class in university where they're sort of teaching you about sort of building up from like VHDL, you know, how to kind of like, you know, implement a processor, you'll end up realizing it really is just, you know,
那就是机器码。如果你曾经做过像 NAND to Tetris，或者有另一个游戏，你在网页浏览器上用 NAND 构建逻辑门，或者你在大学里上了一门课，他们某种程度上教你关于某种程度上从 VHDL 构建，你知道，如何某种程度上，你知道，实现一个处理器，你最终会意识到它确实只是，你知道，
hex numbers on a screen that you, you know, end up getting executed in there, that that's your program. And every kind of family of processors has a different set of instructions, a different way of organizing those operations. And to write a program in it, you know, you would have to sit there and really write, write, you know, a hex, you know, or you can write binary too. But you know, most people would write it in hex. And that's the way we sort of think about it, because it gives you the nice byte delineation. And you would not do that after about maybe one time of doing that you would not want to do that anymore and so as an example like when we did Motorola 68k processors which is just you know one of these families when I was in in university and we had to do this as a task like you know write some you know machine code
屏幕上的十六进制数字，你，你知道，最终在那里被执行，那就是你的程序。每一种处理器家族都有不同的指令集，组织这些操作的不同方式。要用它编写程序，你知道，你必须坐在那里，真正编写，编写，你知道，十六进制，你知道，或者你也可以编写二进制。但你知道，大多数人会用十六进制编写。这就是我们某种程度上思考它的方式，因为它给了你很好的字节界定。你不会在做完大约一次之后再想那样做了，所以作为一个例子，比如当我们做 Motorola 68k 处理器时，这只是，你知道，这些家族之一，当我在大学时，我们必须把这作为一个任务，比如，你知道，编写一些，你知道，机器码
and I did that once before sort of realizing wait a minute I'm just going to write a program to be like a crappy assembler uh and you know do that and so then that moves us to assembly language and so assembly language is just like a very light skin over this machine code so you're pretty much have a one-to-one correspondence but you're writing english symbols so instead of hex code 47 being the move operator where you move you know one set of bytes to another location you would say mov move right that's a lot easier and then the registers each have names rather than just numbers like you know r8 or whatever for register 8 and so this is the first time we encounter what would you would call a compiler And the compiler takes those English letters or whatever language you're writing in letters and maps them directly and emits the bytecode. So does that mean
我之前做过一次，某种程度上意识到，等一下，我只是要写一个程序，成为一个糟糕的汇编器，嗯，你知道，做那个，所以然后那把我们带到了汇编语言，所以汇编语言就像是机器码上的一层非常轻的皮肤，所以你几乎有一对一的对应关系，但你正在编写英语符号，所以与其十六进制代码 47 是移动操作符，在那里你移动，你知道，一组字节到另一个位置，你会说 mov 移动，对吧，那容易多了，然后寄存器每个都有名字，而不是仅仅是数字，比如，你知道，r8 或其他什么，对于寄存器 8，所以这是我们第一次遇到你会称之为编译器的东西，而编译器获取那些英文字母或无论你正在编写什么语言的字母，并直接映射它们并发出字节码。所以那意味着
that it's reversible? Like, can you go from machine code to assembly code? Yes, great, great question. So you can, it's called disassembly. And for assembly, and I'll talk about a caveat here in a second, it's pretty straightforward so if you take a program that lives and you and you haven't gone we had oh that was way that was many years ago but um we had the folks from i think intel in here talking about obfuscating your program codes that people can't do that um and they can't sort of like patch it or do what would in video games would be hacking or you know and and more critical software trying to get your keys or something um but yeah so you can do disassembly so you can take the bytes flowing through your
它是可逆的吗？比如，你可以从机器码到汇编代码吗？是的，很好，很好的问题。所以你可以，它被称为反汇编。对于汇编，我会在这里谈论一个警告，它非常直接，所以如果你拿一个存在的程序，你，你还没有去，我们有，哦，那是很久以前的事了，但，嗯，我们有来自，我想是英特尔的人在这里谈论混淆你的程序代码，这样人们就不能那样做，而且他们不能某种程度上修补它，或者做在视频游戏中会是黑客攻击，或者，你知道，以及更关键的软件试图获取你的密钥之类的，但是的，所以你可以进行反汇编，所以你可以获取流经你的
processor and sort of convert them back to assembly because yeah it's it's a very direct mapping got it okay um so the caveat there that that i was already alluding to and you can can help here it's not too bad in assembly is what i've described far, you kind of do in a single pass. But that also turns out to be easier to do better than and you know, it's frustrating. So you wouldn't want to stay there very long, which is you may want, you may want to have an example where you have a loop. And so when you're on a loop, you want to go back in your program to somewhere previous, right? Just get forward if you have an if statement. And if you were doing what I described initially, and that's kind of like a single pass compiler,
处理器的字节，并某种程度上将它们转换回汇编，因为是的，它，它是一个非常直接的映射。明白了，好的，嗯，那里的警告，我已经在暗示了，你可以，可以在这里帮忙，它在汇编中并不太坏，正如我到目前为止所描述的，你某种程度上在单次通过中完成。但这也被证明比，而且你知道，令人沮丧，更容易做得更好。所以你不会想在那里待太久，也就是你可能想要，你可能想要有一个例子，你有循环。所以当你在一个循环中时，你想回到你程序中之前的某个地方，对吧？如果你有一个 if 语句，只是向前。如果你正在做我最初描述的事情，那有点像单次通过编译器，
you would have to calculate, go down, figure it out. It's eight instructions for my loop. So I need to go back to that branch statement and say, jump eight instructions down. And that'd be really annoying. So what people do is implement the ability to add labels. So you can put a label, end of loop. And you can know, jump JMP, and then you can put end of loop. The issue is
你必须计算，向下，弄清楚它。我的循环有八条指令。所以我需要回到那个分支语句，说，跳转八条指令向下。那会非常烦人。所以人们所做的是实现添加标签的能力。所以你可以放一个标签，循环结束。而且你可以知道，跳转 JMP，然后你可以放循环结束。问题是
when you're doing a single pass compiler, you're scanning down, it says jump, end of loop, but it's never seen the symbol end of loop. So it doesn't know where to jump to, right. And so now you get what we call sort of a two pass compiler. So now you start to get what you would kind of think about variable names and labels and jump statements. It's not really that much extra, but it your productivity goes way higher. And for many years, people coded an assembly with two pass compilers. And the two pass just means first scan through to find all of the symbols that are names, and their you know, know locations and then on the second pass does the actual emit the the machine code and now it knows oh this offset is you know this many instructions
当你进行单次通过编译器时，你正在向下扫描，它说跳转，循环结束，但它从未见过符号循环结束。所以它不知道跳到哪里，对吧。所以现在你得到了我们称之为某种两次通过编译器的东西。所以现在你开始得到你某种程度上会考虑变量名和标签以及跳转语句的东西。它并没有多出那么多，但你的生产力会高得多。而且多年来，人们用两次通过编译器编写汇编代码。而两次通过只是意味着第一次扫描以找到所有是名字的符号，以及它们的，你知道，知道位置，然后在第二次通过时进行实际的发出，发出机器码，现在它知道，哦，这个偏移量是，你知道，这么多指令
down and it's able to produce the the machine code but that's it says it does it literally do it in two passes because i could also imagine like anytime you see a jump forward you just keep track of it and then you go back and fill it in i i mean but that sure but that's still you can't do it in a single it's not one pass because you have to go back up right and right so i guess like the big o notation kind of thing like how do you want to call it i'm sure i'm sure they get pretty sophisticated there's probably you know it's just calling out that the progression i guess in here but still these assembly languages you're you're writing in um you know there's kind of some asterisk here but
下来，它就能生成机器码，但仅此而已。它确实是分两遍完成的，因为我也可以想象，每当你看到一个向前跳转的指令，你只需记录下来，然后再回头去填充它。我的意思是，这当然可以，但这仍然不是单遍扫描，因为它不是一次完成的，因为你必须回头，对吧？所以我想，就像大O符号那种东西，你想怎么称呼它呢？我相信他们肯定做得非常复杂，可能只是在这里指出了这种演进过程，但这些汇编语言，你正在编写的……你知道，这里面有一些星号（注意事项）。
for the most part you're writing it per you know kind of processor so if you want to write it on a you know if you're going to use an arduino which is i think based on a pick chip, then you need to use the pick flavor of assembly. If you want to do this in, you know, Motorola 68k x86 processor, arm processor, if you're, you know, going to run on a phone, every one of these has a different set of instructions, and therefore a different assembly language. And so again, that gets really crappy, if you want to ever write for more than one thing, or you want to go faster because you're pretty much still basically writing one line of code per instruction, um, which is going to make you very easily able to sort of intuit about sort of like runtime and complexity
在大多数情况下，你是针对特定的处理器来编写的。所以如果你想在 Arduino 上编写，我认为它是基于 PIC 芯片的，那么你就需要使用 PIC 风格的汇编语言。如果你想在摩托罗拉 68k、x86 处理器或 ARM 处理器上做这件事，或者如果你要在手机上运行，每一个都有不同的指令集，因此也就有不同的汇编语言。所以再说一次，如果你想为不止一种东西编写代码，或者你想提高速度，这就会变得非常糟糕，因为你基本上还是在为每条指令写一行代码，这会让你很容易直观地理解运行时间和复杂度。
of things, um, a little easier than my high level language. Um, but, but again, it gets, it's kind of frustrating and there are concepts for still everything that's in a high level language sort of has to be capable of being done in assembly language so you still see things like doing function calls so jumping to a function and pushing stuff onto the stack for some processors those things are strictly implemented by a higher language compiler but some processors actually have support for that even Even at the assembly language level does the new would sort of start to call those things complex instruction sets, CISC versus risk reduced instruction set computers.
比起高级语言，这稍微容易一些。但是，这又变得很令人沮丧，而且高级语言中的所有概念在汇编语言中都必须能够实现，所以你仍然会看到函数调用之类的东西，比如跳转到函数并将内容压入堆栈。对于某些处理器，这些东西是由高级语言编译器严格实现的，但有些处理器实际上在汇编语言层面就提供了支持。人们开始把这些称为复杂指令集（CISC），相对于精简指令集计算机（RISC）。
And so there's a whole separate topic. We'll sort of leave this here because we'll go forever and move up, move up the, the family tree, I guess, to, to higher, higher level languages.
这是一个完全独立的话题。我们先把它放在这里，因为如果我们继续深入下去就没完没了了，我们还是往上走，沿着家谱往上走，去看看更高级的语言吧。
Yeah, that makes sense so so uh um so so every programming language like that you read about like c c++ java python they're all considered high level yeah right yeah yeah yeah i mean i don't i there's degrees to that i guess you know you but at least when i sort of started learning about this and you know they shift over time right there was early on it was you writing an assembly or you're writing in you know something that wasn't assembly and anything that wasn't assembly was you know high level and the idea there being in my mind at least the delineation um and it may be it's moved over time. But if you write a line of code, and it produces sort of an arbitrary number of machine instructions, then you're now writing in a high level language.
是的，这很有道理。所以，你读到的每一种编程语言，比如 C、C++、Java、Python，它们都被认为是高级语言，对吧？是的，没错。我的意思是，我想这其中是有程度之分的。至少当我开始学习这个的时候，你知道，它们随着时间在变化。早些时候，你要么用汇编编写，要么用非汇编语言编写，而任何非汇编语言都被认为是高级语言。在我看来，这种界定可能随着时间推移而改变了。但如果你写一行代码，它能产生任意数量的机器指令，那么你现在就是在用高级语言编写。
Got it. Okay. So in a line of C code, just as an example, or Java or whatever you can write you know a plus b divided by c times d you know to the power two whatever right that's that's one line but it's many many many you know assembly operations to do that depending on architecture um and the compiler now is is able to target different backends so if you write you know and we'll talk about sort of c c plus plus here for a second if you if you're writing in C or C++, you can compile against many different processors. So you could write one program that runs on ARM or on x86, because the compiler is picking up your code, and we're going to build a building, sort of finding the symbols,
明白了。好的。所以以 C 语言为例，或者 Java 之类的，你可以写 a 加 b 除以 c 乘以 d 的 2 次方等等，那是一行代码，但根据架构的不同，它需要很多很多汇编操作来完成。现在的编译器能够针对不同的后端进行编译，所以如果你用 C 或 C++ 编写，你可以针对许多不同的处理器进行编译。因此，你可以编写一个能在 ARM 或 x86 上运行的程序，因为编译器会获取你的代码，构建一个结构，找到符号，
building a syntax tree, and it knows how to emit the proper machine code for you know executing that program and it does it can do that with many passes depending on the compilers but by many compilers also emit a sort of intermediate representation so even different front ends so you could say like an llv llvm you'll see things that can target, you know, the LLVM IR intermediate representation, which is something which mean the sort of machine code assembly and the high level language that lots and lots of front ends can compile into. And then there's a specific set of operations and libraries and team working on taking that intermediate representation and compiling it down to your specific final machine. And so then that's called the backend. So you have the front end compiling to intermediate representation and in the backend,
构建语法树，并且它知道如何为你执行该程序生成正确的机器码。根据编译器的不同，它可以通过多次扫描来完成。但许多编译器也会生成一种中间表示（IR），所以即使是不同的前端，你也可以说像 LLVM，你会看到一些可以针对 LLVM IR（中间表示）的东西，这是介于机器码汇编和高级语言之间的东西，许多前端都可以编译成这种格式。然后有一套特定的操作和库，团队致力于将该中间表示编译成你特定的最终机器码。这就是所谓的后端。所以你有编译到中间表示的前端，以及后端，
taking it from intermediate representation to a specific class of processor. Got it. I see. So if you wanted to write a new language you could you could you could create a language that compiles to the llvm immediate representation and then you'd be guaranteed that it would run on all these different processors and not only that you're also going to benefit from a bunch of optimizations that the sort of like imagine loop unrolling so you write a loop in in this intermediate representation and now the sophisticated folks across all these languages economies of scale kind of thing can implement loop unrolling or some stuff we're going to talk about later but you know it can implement it at the ir level and then you can benefit from it got it cool it makes sense so now you mentioned Java as well. Java gets a special shout out here, which is that when Java is compiled and this starts to say, you know, these are words we use, but you know, requirement that it has to map cleanly. targets sort of an intermediate representation called the the jvm the java virtual machine byte
将它从中间表示转换为特定类别的处理器。明白了。我懂了。所以如果你想编写一种新语言，你可以创建一个编译到 LLVM 中间表示的语言，然后你就能保证它可以在所有这些不同的处理器上运行。不仅如此，你还能从各种优化中受益，比如循环展开。你在这种中间表示中编写一个循环，现在这些跨越所有语言的复杂专家们，利用规模经济，可以实现循环展开或其他我们稍后会讨论的东西。你可以在 IR 层面实现它，然后你就能从中受益。明白了，很酷，这很有道理。那么你刚才也提到了 Java。Java 在这里要特别提一下，当 Java 被编译时——这开始涉及到我们使用的术语——它必须能够清晰地映射。它针对的是一种称为 JVM（Java 虚拟机）字节码的中间表示，
code and so it does get compiled and it has all this you know optimization and stuff that can happen and then it produces uh basically a machine code but the machine it targets is the the java virtual machine not an individual processor and when it was first developed this was a huge boon because now you talk about portability you can run on anything that there was a jvm for the jvm for and llvm wasn't really a big time so you know you know again times change but at the time this was like seen as like a really big thing and um sun microsystems at the time you know we're sort of sort of pushing that hey uh java really you know know, runs on I forget, they had an ad, you know, some obscene number of devices, and, you know, has this ability. And so there, you're compiling it down. And then the Java virtual machine has an implementation per, you know, kind of
所以它确实被编译了，并且拥有所有这些优化功能，然后它基本上生成了机器码，但它针对的机器是 Java 虚拟机，而不是单个处理器。当它最初被开发出来时，这是一个巨大的福音，因为现在你谈论的是可移植性，你可以在任何有 JVM 的地方运行。当时 LLVM 还没有那么流行，所以时代在变，但在当时，这被视为一件非常了不起的事情。当时的 Sun Microsystems 确实在推动这一点，嘿，Java 真的可以在——我忘了，他们有个广告，说可以在某种数量惊人的设备上运行，并且具有这种能力。所以，你在那里把它编译下来。然后 Java 虚拟机针对每种架构都有一个实现，
architecture. So it has an ARM implementation, and it has an x86 implementation. And the implementation of that virtual machine is to take that bytecode and pretend it emulates right emulates this sort of conceptual computer that is like a almost like a lowest common denominator but on some processors it may be able to be very efficient with a certain operation and others not but you don't have to worry about that. Because, you know, it's sort of just handled for you. And all of the standard libraries can have sort of special treatment or efficiencies added. And so this was a very interesting approach. But it sort of threads the line here where you have, it's not a scripting language, we'll talk about that is in a second. But it's not a true compile in that there's still an emulator a virtual machine as it were that sits in the middle here uh and and sort
所以它有 ARM 实现，也有 x86 实现。该虚拟机的实现方式是获取字节码并模拟——它模拟这种概念上的计算机，就像一个最低公分母。但在某些处理器上，它可能能够非常高效地执行某种操作，而在其他处理器上则不然，但你不必担心这一点。因为，你知道，它基本上是为你处理好的。所有的标准库都可以有特殊的处理或效率提升。所以这是一种非常有趣的方法。但它在这里界限模糊，它不是脚本语言，我们稍后会讨论。但它也不是真正的编译，因为中间仍然有一个模拟器，也就是虚拟机，
of that's the program that's actually running so that program is running your program um and so the compiler is not targeting a machine the compiler is targeting well it is targeting machine but it's not targeting a physical machine so if i understand correctly right so the difference is with llvm you're going to this immediate representation but then you're you're you're you're uh instantly going to machine code and so now you have machine code that can only run on uh that architecture but with java you're still going to this intermediate format but you're not doing that second step to go to machine code uh at compile time you're doing it at runtime yeah so the intermediate representation is not really executed right there's no program well again you could
这就是实际运行的程序。所以那个程序在运行你的程序。因此，编译器不是针对机器的，编译器是针对——好吧，它确实是针对机器，但它不是针对物理机器。如果我理解正确的话，区别在于使用 LLVM，你进入了这个中间表示，然后你立即进入了机器码，所以现在你有了只能在该架构上运行的机器码。但使用 Java，你仍然进入了这个中间格式，但你没有进行第二步去生成机器码，而是在运行时才进行。是的，所以中间表示并没有真正被执行，对吧？没有程序——好吧，再说一次，你可以
could write one but the intention isn't that there's a program that runs the intermediate representation versus in java that there is a program the jvm that runs your you know jvm byte code got it okay so then now we get to to sort of uh scripting and scripting and interpreters the idea is is sort of similar it's very rhyming which uh you know basic was this way other things are this way and that is rather than a compiler you're running a program that needs to work per architecture but that program is doing all of the work at runtime of executing your script. So it's converting the symbols you wrote into the letters you wrote into symbols, it's building whatever it needs to to be able to execute it. So if you're, you know, setting a variable name, like Jason was mentioning, it's keeping track of that, but it's doing it sort of fresh every run. And so it's opening it up. And if you have,
写一个，但目的不是有一个程序来运行中间表示。而在 Java 中，确实有一个程序（JVM）来运行你的 JVM 字节码。明白了。好的，那么现在我们谈谈脚本和解释器。这个想法是类似的，非常押韵。Basic 是这样，其他语言也是这样。那就是你不是使用编译器，而是运行一个需要针对每种架构工作的程序，但该程序在运行时完成了执行脚本的所有工作。所以它把你写的符号转换成字母，它构建执行所需的任何东西。所以如果你像 Jason 提到的那样设置一个变量名，它会跟踪它，但它是每次运行都重新做一遍。所以它在打开它。如果你有，
as an example, you know, a typo halfway down, you're going to find out about it out about it a down your programs execution or whatever. And so it's not attempting to in this sort of level zero, it's not attempting to do anything other than just sort of execute your script, right? So if you've ever written Python, and you have a, you know, typo at the bottom of your program, and your whole program runs, and then doesn't output, you know, the answer, because it crashes at the end, this is happening, it's not trying to compile, it's not trying to look ahead, it's just there is the program that's running on per architecture is parsing the script input at runtime. Yeah, I mean, you can this this is starting to really boggle my mind now that i'm
举个例子，中间有一个拼写错误，你会在程序执行到那里时发现它。所以它在零级层面并没有试图做任何事情，只是执行你的脚本，对吧？所以如果你写过 Python，并且在程序底部有一个拼写错误，你的整个程序运行了，然后没有输出答案，因为它在最后崩溃了，这就是正在发生的事情。它没有试图编译，没有试图预判，只是在每种架构上运行的程序在运行时解析脚本输入。是的，我的意思是，这开始让我感到非常困惑，现在我
thinking about it like in python you can open the interactive interpreter and you can actually have you can write if statements and for loops and anything you can write in python you can write in there and so you can actually like write a for loop in that for loop have a break if a certain condition is met and then keep going and so like python has to kind of remember that like you put that break there but it doesn't really know what's going to happen after the break because like you you literally haven't written it yet and so that's to kind of keep track of all of these things while you're while it's interpreting what you're writing it's also not that it's impossible other places but it becomes much more straightforward to things like python loves to do which is like modify definitions on the fly
想到这一点，比如在 Python 中，你可以打开交互式解释器，你可以编写 if 语句和 for 循环，任何你能在 Python 中写的东西你都可以在那里写。所以你实际上可以写一个 for 循环，在那个 for 循环中，如果满足某个条件就中断，然后继续。所以 Python 必须记住你把那个中断放在那里，但它并不知道中断之后会发生什么，因为你字面上还没有写出来。所以它必须在解释你所写内容的同时跟踪所有这些事情。这并不是说在其他地方不可能，但对于 Python 喜欢做的事情来说，这变得更加直接，比如动态修改定义。
right so like changing variable names to another type or to even modifying functions that are on a class because all those things are sort of held in memory right like the the sort of processing the compilation goes into memory and it's just held and is done sort of in real time like at execution and so modifying that stuff is more obviously you know straightforward to implement more it's obvious, but it's you can kind of envision how you would do that if it's like a thing sitting in RAM, versus if you've compiled it into something that you admitted to the disk, right, and you're sort of executing out of read only memory. And again, there's lots of things that blur these lines. But yeah, so scripting,
对，比如将变量名更改为另一种类型，甚至修改类上的函数，因为所有这些东西都存储在内存中。处理和编译进入内存，并且是在执行时实时完成的。所以修改这些东西显然更直接。这很明显，但你可以想象如果你把它放在 RAM 中会怎么做，而不是把它编译成你发送到磁盘的东西，然后你从只读内存中执行它。再说一次，有很多东西模糊了这些界限。但是的，所以脚本，
and if when people sort of think about it, it can be slower because at runtime, you have to do more, right? You have to convert the mapping. You don't need to know that, you know, your variable name is some complex, you know, set of underscores. When you're doing the compile, you just map it to this is the first variable I've seen. So it's variable lookup table entry zero, right? And it's literally just a pointer or just an index zero and then every time you see that you're keeping track of it but in the final program it all gets taken away right because it's just everything points to the right spot and all those things are resolved when you're doing scripting though when you're marching down the program you that table has to live in memory
当人们想到它时，它可能会更慢，因为在运行时，你必须做更多的事情。你必须转换映射。当你进行编译时，你不需要知道你的变量名是一组复杂的下划线。你只需将其映射为我见过的第一个变量。所以它是变量查找表条目零，对吧？它字面上只是一个指针或索引零，然后每次你看到它时，你都在跟踪它。但在最终程序中，所有这些都被去掉了，因为一切都指向正确的位置，并且当你进行脚本编写时，所有这些东西都会被解析。然而，当你沿着程序执行时，那个表必须存在于内存中，
and you have to go do that look up right right? Oh, Jason's most complicated, very long named, but not meaningful variable that has to get parsed, which is a lot of characters and has to get that mapping to take place every time it's seen sort of like at runtime. And so this gets to why people kind of say
你必须去进行查找。对吧？哦，Jason 的那个最复杂、名字很长但没有意义的变量，必须被解析，这有很多字符，并且必须在每次看到它时在运行时进行映射。所以这就解释了为什么人们会说
scripting would be slower. But as Jason mentioned, the advantage is because execution is happening at like, you know, kind of while you're doing it and all these steps are you can also modify the steps and it becomes very easy to do and to interactive and to kind of see what's
脚本会更慢。但正如 Jason 提到的，优势在于因为执行是在你操作时发生的，所有这些步骤你也可以修改这些步骤，而且变得非常容易操作、交互，并且可以看到
happening and um you know very straightforward yeah that makes sense i believe i believe if you um your machine code is loaded into the process memory that like you can't touch like if you start writing in the chunk of memory where your machine code went it'll the the you know like they'll they'll assume that you're trying to do something nefarious or something or a mistake but but in python there's probably no way to catch that a lot of early viruses did this like self-modifying code so they you know people screen them they look, but then they get modified to do something that looks that is nefarious, you know, at execution. Yeah, a lot of people, a lot of systems will try to stop or prevent that and assume that
发生了什么。而且，你知道，非常直接。是的，这很有道理。我相信，如果你……你的机器码被加载到进程内存中，你不能触碰它。如果你开始在机器码所在的内存块中写入，他们会假设你在试图做一些邪恶的事情或者犯了错误。但在 Python 中，可能没有办法捕捉到这一点。许多早期的病毒就是这样做的，比如自修改代码。所以他们……人们筛选它们，它们看起来没问题，但在执行时被修改以做一些看起来邪恶的事情。是的，很多人，很多系统会试图阻止或防止这种情况，并假设
you were making a mistake and at best preventing you from doing something you really weren't supposed to do. Yeah, that makes sense. But yeah, that's it. Yeah, that's mind bendy stuff when you start talking about that. Okay, two couple other things I wanted to cover briefly, you'll hear about.
你犯了一个错误，充其量是阻止你做一些你真的不应该做的事情。是的，这很有道理。但确实如此。是的，当你开始谈论这些时，这真是令人费解。好的，还有两件事我想简要介绍一下，你会听到的。
So one is a JIT, which is just in time. So for scripting languages, all is not lost about these runtimes. So in Python, as an example, or other things, you can have a JIT, which says, hey, I've noticed that this piece of script has been executed. This function has been called many, many, many times. So I'm going to rather than every time I get to it,
一个是 JIT，即即时编译。对于脚本语言，关于这些运行时的东西并没有完全丢失。在 Python 中，或者其他语言中，你可以有一个 JIT，它说，嘿，我注意到这段脚本已经被执行了。这个函数已经被调用了很多很多次。所以我打算，而不是每次我执行到它时，
do all the parsing and all the work again, it can effectively do a compilation step, right? Can go ahead and resolve all of those things, things it can even go could do, you know, implementing them all the way out to machine code or the operations or whatever right um java has this as well well for bytecode but basically at runtime sort of observing that you're about to do something or that you've done it before and pre-computing and storing those results so that the next time you do it time you do it you get your execution that that's sort of the concept i'm probably doing a bad job but of just in time right it's just in the nick of time i've provided you a you know optimized thing to run um right and you could do the loop unrolling and all of that stuff like if you know that this four loops only get executed four times or you don't know it but you're confident then you could unroll it yep um
都重新进行所有的解析和工作，它可以有效地执行一个编译步骤。它可以继续并解析所有这些东西，甚至可以做到将它们一直实现到机器码或操作等等。Java 也有这个功能，针对字节码，但基本上是在运行时观察到你即将做某事，或者你以前做过，并预先计算并存储这些结果，以便下次你做的时候，你就能得到执行。这就是即时编译的概念。我可能解释得不好，但它就是在紧要关头，我为你提供了一个优化过的东西来运行。对，你可以进行循环展开等等。如果你知道这个 for 循环只执行四次，或者你不知道，但你很自信，那么你就可以展开它。是的。
and you could even do code analysis to do it, right? Again, you know, extend these all have like research directions or implementations and various, you know, features. And then the last thing I want to talk about that also blurs the line, though, is something that's actually interesting you've ever seen, which is profile guided optimization. So some of these drag races, I guess you call them between sort of scripting languages and compiled languages will show, hey, actually, this Python code is a lot faster, because
你甚至可以进行代码分析来做到这一点。再说一次，这些都有研究方向或实现以及各种功能。我想谈的最后一件事，它也模糊了界限，但实际上很有趣，就是配置引导优化（PGO）。所以，脚本语言和编译语言之间的一些“直线加速赛”会显示，嘿，实际上，这段 Python 代码快得多，因为
in this case, the, you know, during runtime Python, the interpreter observed these behaviors and perform this optimization that you couldn't have known a priori, it had to be known, sort of like at runtime, and it gains this advantage. It's true, that can happen't have known a priori. It had to be known sort of like at runtime and it gains this advantage. It's true. That can happen. That is a thing. And it can be really cool. In compiled languages,
在这种情况下，在运行时，Python 解释器观察到了这些行为并执行了这种你无法预先知道的优化，它必须在运行时才知道，并获得了这种优势。这是真的，这种情况确实会发生。这是真的。这种情况确实会发生。这确实是一回事。而且它可能非常酷。在编译语言中，
we're starting to see some work around profile guided optimization, which is run your program and you record a bunch of statistics about how many times various loops. By default, was this if statement skipped 99% of the time and even compilers do some of this sorry even processors do some of this to help with
我们开始看到一些关于配置引导优化的工作，即运行你的程序并记录关于各种循环执行次数的统计数据。默认情况下，这个 if 语句是否 99% 的时间都被跳过了？甚至编译器也会做一些这样的事情，抱歉，甚至处理器也会做一些这样的事情来帮助
optimization but sort of recording statistics about what was executed how much and and various sort of things and and that the sort of call it happy path you make a guess i'm just going to assume this is going to be true and i'll add a little check if it's true i'm going I'm going to gain this boost. And if it's not true, then I'll have to execute something a little slower, right? No free lunch. But it does this via a profiling. So you've profiled your code. And now this optimization uses that profile of the code as a sort of almost second compilation. So you run the compilation, you insert all these sort of like, you know, extra hooks to measure stuff. You look at the output, and then you run compiling again, that uses that as input, and it's able to sort of be more thoughtful about how to perform certain optimization steps of compiling. Cool. So if people are really excited about compilers and interpreters and they want to work on the Python VM or the C++ like GCC or something, where does most of that work take place? My guess is probably like government programs and giant companies and stuff. But like, what would be your career advice for them so there are folks working at you know big company big tech companies that you sort of hear right if we if we sort of name some um you know dart you know at google or swift at apple or
优化。但记录关于执行了什么、执行了多少以及各种事情的统计数据，以及所谓的“快乐路径”，你做一个猜测，我只是假设这是真的，我会加一个小检查，如果它是真的，我就会获得这个提升。如果不是真的，那么我就必须执行一些稍微慢一点的东西，对吧？没有免费的午餐。但它通过分析来做到这一点。所以你分析了你的代码。现在这种优化使用该代码的配置文件作为一种几乎是第二次编译的东西。所以你运行编译，你插入所有这些额外的钩子来测量东西。你查看输出，然后你再次运行编译，它使用该输出作为输入，并且它能够更深思熟虑地执行某些编译优化步骤。酷。所以如果人们对编译器和解释器非常兴奋，并且他们想在 Python VM 或 C++（如 GCC）上工作，大部分工作是在哪里进行的？我的猜测可能是政府项目和巨型公司之类的。但是，你对他们的职业建议是什么？所以，有一些人在大科技公司工作，你听说过，对吧？如果我们列举一些，比如 Google 的 Dart，或者 Apple 的 Swift，或者
i think java is still at oracle um you know obviously those places have teams that work on these things and you can go work on them um but i think a lot of it also happens as hobbyists do stuff. You know, in university, this is compilers and interpreters is a course you can take. If you want to do it as a job. What I don't know is like how you as a job without working at a big company that has a vested interest in it, you sort of get paid to make a very cool llvm and intermediate representation optimization definitely something you can do and if you have a company that will sponsor their work which is you know maybe a hard thing to find i don't know that it's it's not like writing a game we just do it and then people pay you for for good output
我想 Java 仍然在 Oracle。显然，这些地方有团队在研究这些东西，你可以去那里工作。但我认为其中很多也发生在业余爱好者身上。你知道，在大学里，编译器和解释器是你选修的一门课程。如果你想把它作为一份工作。我不知道的是，如果你不在一家对此有既得利益的大公司工作，你如何作为一份工作获得报酬来制作一个非常酷的 LLVM 和中间表示优化。这绝对是你能够做的事情，如果你有一家公司愿意赞助他们的工作，这可能是一件很难找到的事情。我不知道，这不像写游戏，你只是做了，然后人们为你好的输出付费。
be very difficult to write like a new language that someone would pay you just to like consult on um my opinion maybe i'm wrong yeah i think you're right i think even if if you set out to you know create a new language uh i think even then i would probably start by working for one of these big companies. I think like, I want to say one of the military labs is like the chief person on GCC, like Sandia or one of these labs, I don't remember. But basically, you know, for all of these things, LLVM, Swift, GCC, you know, look at who their biggest sponsors are, right?
编写一种人们会付钱让你咨询的新语言会非常困难。我的观点，也许我错了。是的，我想你是对的。我想即使你着手创建一种新语言，我想即使那样，我也可能会先为这些大公司之一工作。我想说的是，其中一个军事实验室是 GCC 的主要负责人，比如 Sandia 或这些实验室之一，我不记得了。但基本上，对于所有这些东西，LLVM、Swift、GCC，看看谁是他们最大的赞助商，对吧？
Look at who the domain name of the email addresses that are most prevalent on the mailing list, right? It's not hard to figure out who is actually putting in most, you know, of the effort for that particular compiler or interpreter and then once you know that then then uh then it's a matter of you know creating changes uh you know basically doing that doing that job kind of pro bono for a little while and proving yourself to those folks um you know becoming ingratiated um by those folks and then and then reaching out to them and saying hey i want to do this full time um and so if that's something that interests you that's that's the path for it to do that. You don't need to be a master propagandist or anything like that.
看看邮件列表上最普遍的电子邮件地址的域名是谁，对吧？弄清楚谁实际上为那个特定的编译器或解释器投入了大部分精力并不难。一旦你知道了这一点，那么就是创造变革的问题，基本上是免费做那份工作一段时间，向那些人证明你自己，被那些人接纳，然后联系他们说，嘿，我想全职做这个。所以如果这是你感兴趣的事情，这就是实现它的途径。你不需要成为一个大师级的宣传家或类似的人。
It's a very simple formula. Just put some sweat equity into that. Talk to the folks who are also putting in that sweat equity and that's how you can do it. I'll give two shout outs quickly. I don't think this is the first thing you do, right? Write programs for a while before attempting to write your own programming language.
这是一个非常简单的公式。只需投入一些汗水。与那些也投入汗水的人交谈，这就是你可以做到的方式。我会快速给两个建议。我不认为这是你做的第一件事。在尝试编写自己的编程语言之前，先编写一段时间的程序。
Probably a good move. But two resources that I think are really useful here, many more, but people would have recommended the Dragon compiler book before, but I never made it through it. Anyways, the first one is by and I might not say the last name correctly, but Robert Nystrom Nystrom, and he wrote a game design patterns, like design patterns for games that's very useful. Definitely check that out. I think you can read it free online, but also read free online crafting interpreters. So crafting interpreters.com. And I think there's like, you know, a web version, but I think there's
这可能是一个明智的举动。但我认为这里有两个非常有用的资源，还有很多，但人们以前会推荐《龙书》（编译器设计），但我从来没看完它。无论如何，第一个是由——我可能说不对姓氏，但 Robert Nystrom，他写了《游戏设计模式》，这对游戏非常有用。一定要去看看。我想你可以免费在线阅读，但也去读读免费在线的《Crafting Interpreters》。所以 craftinginterpreters.com。我想那里有网页版，但我认为还有
like actually now a physical book as well. And I haven't sort of gone through it and like implement myself. It's on my, my to-do list. Um, but definitely a way of talking about how would you add an interpreter, implement polymorphism, how would you, you know, handle variables and sort of building up your own programming language, uh, of you know not going to be i don't think state of the art you know pushing the envelope but but definitely giving you a flavor for this which i think is really useful to know how how some of this stuff works and then in the sort of opposite side of that i i mentioned it but nand game.com there's also nand to tetris but nandgame.com is really easy to jump in and start showing you like starts oh like one touch too low maybe for what we talked about today
实际上现在也有实体书。我还没有通读它并自己实现。它在我的待办事项清单上。但绝对是一种谈论如何添加解释器、实现多态性、如何处理变量以及构建你自己的编程语言的方法。我不认为这是最先进的，但我认为它能让你对这些东西如何工作有一个了解。然后在相反的一面，我提到了它，但 nandgame.com 还有 nand2tetris，但 nandgame.com 非常容易上手，并开始向你展示，哦，对于我们今天谈论的内容来说，可能有点太底层了。
where how do you build a nand gate how do you make an org gate from a nand gate but quickly jumps in basically how do you build um you know the actual processor components, the parts that do math, how do the bits get added? And why is it that a certain machine code byte evokes a certain behavior from the pieces of the computer, the actual silicon? Anyways, and so you can just like play it
如何构建一个与非门，如何从与非门制作一个或门，但它很快就跳到了基本上如何构建实际的处理器组件，执行数学运算的部分，位是如何相加的？为什么特定的机器码字节会从计算机的各个部分（实际的硅片）中引发特定的行为？无论如何，你可以像玩游戏一样在网页浏览器中玩它，
in your web browser and, you know, just sort of go at it. You might have to Google some help. I did, sorry. But, you know, how do you implement registers? How do address buses work? Anyway, so that's nan game.com. We'll put them both in the show notes, but two useful resources. There's a modern take on this game too, called a Turing complete. Oh, I've seen this, but I didn't want to pitch it cause I haven't tried it. I haven't tried it either. So I haven't tried NAND to Tetris either, but it has amazing reviews.
然后直接开始。你可能需要 Google 一些帮助。我做过，抱歉。但是，如何实现寄存器？地址总线是如何工作的？无论如何，这就是 nandgame.com。我们会把它们都放在节目说明中，但这是两个有用的资源。这个游戏也有一个现代版本，叫做 Turing Complete。哦，我见过这个，但我不想推荐它，因为我还没试过。我也没试过。所以我也没有试过 NAND to Tetris，但它有惊人的评价。
I just looked it up. It's overwhelmingly positive. Steve reviews 2,200 reviews. So that is a really good endorsement by the community. Yeah, I've heard a lot of people say it's another good resource. So I'll put it in the show notes too. Cool. All right.
我刚查了一下。它非常正面。2200 条评价。所以这得到了社区非常好的认可。是的，我听说很多人说这是另一个很好的资源。所以我也会把它放在节目说明中。酷。好的。
Thank you, Patrick, for going into a ton of detail here. It was an awesome episode. Thank you, Jessica, for recommending the topic. Phenomenal topic. And thank you to all of our patrons who are kind of supporting the show, helping us reach new people. I was looking through my email the other day about something kind of unrelated and i stumbled upon a email from a listener um a while back who uh who we
谢谢 Patrick 在这里详细介绍。这是一集很棒的节目。谢谢 Jessica 推荐这个话题。非常棒的话题。也感谢我们所有的赞助人，他们支持这个节目，帮助我们接触到新的人。前几天我在查看我的电子邮件，关于一些不相关的事情，我偶然发现了一封来自听众的邮件，很久以前，我们
were able to help them uh you know find their first job i mean that stuff's really inspiring continue to send that to us we read all of them sometimes we read them twice sometimes we find them years later and read them again um so thank you everybody out there for listening for supporting this show and we will see you next time music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution uh to uh patrick and i and uh share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
能够帮助他们找到第一份工作。我的意思是，那些东西真的很鼓舞人心。请继续发送给我们，我们阅读了所有这些邮件，有时我们读了两遍，有时我们几年后发现它们并再次阅读。所以感谢大家收听，支持这个节目，我们下次再见。音乐由 Eric Barn Dollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须提供署名，给 Patrick 和我，并以相同方式共享。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。